don't be getting the aparri jumps I want
to wear that I want like a DLC character
cycling over here where I don't listen
sunglasses my character during a cut
season
hello and welcome to another episode of
trash taste I'm your host for Today Gone
joining me once again are the boys
how are you guys doing today yeah doing
all right you guys have had a busy like
I guess we've all had like a busy week
because I have to say like you really
started off with like the deepest sides
like how's it going yeah he didn't want
to be here yeah honestly yeah it's been
I think it's been a pretty busy week for
all of us either traveling or doing
stuff
um Joe you went to Korea for the first
time didn't you I wanted to ask you
about that finally went to Korea yeah uh
just for like three days for Rocky's
birthday
um yeah it was freaking awesome yeah a
lot I mean big surprise Curry is kind of
cool yeah it is it is a big surprise the
food there was freaking amazing wow no
one knew that before yeah but um yeah I
don't know we were just like just being
tourists for three days just because I
like I've never been there arky's never
been there and it's so close to Japan
yeah right yeah like two out of five
yeah it's like like it takes longer to
get to Okinawa than it does
okay I have no excuse I gotta go
whereabouts did you say uh mostly just
in Seoul yeah I think because we only
had three days so I figured like
traveling yeah I was like should we take
a day to like you know go to like uh you
know Busan or like Gangnam or like other
places like that but I'm just like yeah
I just kind of wanted to explore actual
Seoul because it's a lot bigger than I
thought it was going to be yeah it's
[__] massive yeah yeah because like
you see it on the map right and it's
just like oh it's like not that much
different to like Tokyo for example yeah
it's so much bigger than that because
like even if it just seems down the road
it's like oh it's 20 minutes by train
and I'm like how does that how does that
work but yeah so um because we have like
a couple of friends who like used to
live in Korea quite a long time so we
were just like just give us
recommendations for like the most
touristy [__] we can do yeah yeah
um so we went to like you know the Food
Markets there and like uh you know uh
the I guess the equivalent of Tokyo
Tower in right in uh Seoul which called
the namsam tower I think cool
um yeah it was really cool just super
chill one thing that I was pleasantly
surprised about is that damn everyone
can speak English there yep that's
awesome yeah like I like even if like
you you walk into a store right and
immediately you know they greet you in
Korean but then the moment you start
speaking English they just switch
forward like to full on flow in English
and they're just like oh okay yeah sure
yeah I was surprised by that when I went
to Korea as well because there were
times there was like a few times where I
was just like being sitting with like uh
staring at like the train map trying to
figure out how to get to the place we
want to go yeah and every time we stood
there for like more than a minute
someone came over and was like oh do you
need help in like yeah perfect English
and would explain how to get there in
perfect English and I'm just like yeah
I'm going to see League of Legends uh
okay do you know what stadium that is
yeah I'm trying to watch Imagine Dragons
actually yeah yeah
but it was it was so surprising that
like I I think just not only the fact
that English is such a a pro a prevalent
language that's spoken there but also
just like one massive difference I saw
especially compared to Japan was not
only that but also just how much people
are okay with being on camera because
Aki and I were both vlogging the entire
our entire trip and you know when you go
to like the food markets for example and
you know you'd point the camera at like
the food and stuff like that yeah and I
think my like Japanese brain kicks in
yeah I'm just like I'm not I'm gonna try
and avoid getting random people yeah
into my videos because they might not
like it no there were so many instances
where I would point you know the camera
towards like a food store or something
right and the the man or the woman
behind it would just be like
yay like that was so chill and okay with
being on camera and when we were at this
random food store there was this Korean
couple that just started talking to us
again in perfect English yeah and was
just like oh I wouldn't you know I
wouldn't recommend that if you don't
like spicy food in the most like and I
thought like oh have you lived outside
of Korea before and they're like never
left the city but like the wiser English
so good and it's just I I got a glimpse
of what Japan might be if English was as
commonly used as it was in Korea right
because immediately as a tourist I felt
so much more comfortable like just kind
of talking to people and like I wasn't
as I mean obviously obviously I was
trying to also practice my horrible
Korean as well yeah but at the same time
if it failed then there was always that
that Fail-Safe of all they can speak
moderately do you have a safety note
yeah they have a safety net which I feel
a lot of people who come to Japan as a
tourist on 4 emotionally don't really
get yeah
um purely because English is just not as
commonly spoken and you get that like
honey like face right every time you go
I mean I mean I think we are very very
lucky to know English because it's such
an OP language if you're traveling about
yeah uh and you forget sometimes that
you know uh you forget sometimes when
you travel there are some places that
just don't know much English at all and
Japan is like one of those countries in
comparison to some other major cities
and then a lot of like other like let's
say culturally famous places Japan
doesn't really speak that much English
uh China's a big one as well it's like
it's like if you go to like any major
shiny City a lot of people there do not
speak English and you forget okay
English is only popular in certain
places in the world yeah and there are
some places and you've gotten used to
being able to just like kind of like
push through with you know really slow
English in some places but in Japan it's
a lot harder than other places where
everyone should learn charades
professionals just in case they don't
don't speak English then at least be
like all right I know how to symbolize
what you're doing like yeah can I have
chicken that's not good just stick on
chicken please stick on chicken stick on
chicken
no but uh obviously you know the food
was freaking amazing there like
everything you have a Korean Fried
Chicken of course
three times though like I think I would
have come back with 15 like points of
higher cholesterol I mean I would have
hit it every day I mean we only went
once but it's because we try to have as
much variety of cream food as possible
so we were just like we're just gonna
try everything
um and we saved the Korean chicken till
last because it was like you know it was
gonna slap yeah it's it's pretty hard to
mess up and I I know like and also my
Korean friend was like go to this place
because this is the best place to go and
we went there man I I had a food Wars
moment I I was like three quarters chop
at least eating this chicken and it was
amazing like Fried Chicken Man the
Korean like the the Bobby barbecue that
the K barbecue there was also amazing
and so cheap too yeah it's insane like I
thought eating out in Japan was cheap
but then when you go in and out in Korea
it's like it's even cheaper it's even
cheaper yeah it's great because like
even the food stalls and stuff like that
I I get confused initially because you
know compared to the Yen the the Korean
one is like one extra digit so 300 Yen
in Japan which is about three dollars
it's 3 000 Korean won yeah so when you
when I initially look at the prices my
heart just goes but then I realize it's
like oh wait it's like three bucks yeah
so yeah yeah I got some of the most like
amazing like street food there
um like everyone was so like hospitable
and like friendly and they were so like
eager to be on camera as well like I had
this one woman who like dragged Aki and
I into this uh into the seafood uh place
and she's just like lured Us in we were
like all right let's let's see what
happens yeah and she like dragged us
into her like her shop and she just
started serving us this like fresh crab
meat with like um with uh you know like
on a bed of rice with like a little bit
of kimchi on top yeah and it was the
most amazing thing ever and she was she
was she was plating it up like she was
[__] serving it to Gordon Ramsay she
was just like okay okay I will I will do
the best thing for you here you go
camera camera look at this look like she
kept pointing to the camera being like
focus on this focus on this right I'm
like what are you a YouTuber it's like a
food review Channel happening yeah super
sucks I guess you're always in Japan and
and rightfully so you should assume that
people just don't want to be on camera
yeah yes it's the correct way of
assuming yeah yeah um but that is yes we
had to think that they're just like oh
I'm the movie star get me on camera how
do I look flip the camera around let me
see it oh yeah okay yeah yeah no
honestly likes a lot of them were like
that and you know that and it's more
understandable if it's like younger
people right but a lot of these people
running these food stalls in in Seoul uh
of the older generation which you would
think is not that comfortable with being
on camera right but I guess you know the
place we went to
um the the famous food markets there
there's been so many like food channels
like doing videos there and TV station
doing videos there so I guess they're
just like used to being on camera now
but but I also think
um this is total conjecture by the way I
think
um that when I went to Korea it it felt
it it felt so Eerie right because it was
so like you you go you go to Seoul and
you look around you're like this feels
very much like Tokyo yeah like it like I
remember saying to Sydney if you just
dropped me in a round placed in Seoul
and drop me in a random place in um in
Tokyo if I did not recognize kanji at
all or anything like that I I would have
a trouble distinguishing from like first
looks which city I'm actually in yeah um
they look eerily similar but then you
walk around and Korean people from what
I experienced were just a lot less
reserved than Japanese people right
Japanese people are very very reserved
um and I think I think I I would I would
like to Guess that internet culture has
is just a lot more prevalent in Korean
culture oh I mean it's it's the it's
literally the uh country that kind of
like birthed Esports right that's why
Esports had his like
um had its major Roots put into it so I
would imagine that just the whole
culture over there is much more aware of
just in the internet age and just the
online culture oh yeah I believe so yeah
that's the only country on earth that is
I think fast internet than Japan yeah
yeah I think it has one of the fastest
internet connections in the world I
think it's number one yeah
I can't remember if it still is but a
while back I mean I certainly had no
problems connecting to any Wi-Fi that's
what's up it's so publicly available
yeah exactly yeah taking the drinking
culture at all oh yeah of course I did
oh it is
they are brutal over there man holy [__]
I mean my only saving grace was that Aki
is not that much of a drink so I kind of
had like a scapegoat for that but my God
man like I just even going to like the K
barbecue and just looking across the
room yeah and just seeing like 20 Soju
bottles it's for like three people yeah
that are just sitting there and they're
just laughing and drinking away like
it's nothing I'm like bro I feel sorry
for the doctors that have to check up on
your goddamn liver every year like yeah
oh my God yeah but um I did though I
guess like the the one aspect I guess
the friendly uh the The Stranger
friendliness in Korea that almost
backfired in a way was it was I think it
was like the second night we're in Seoul
and uh we were just kind of walking back
from a restaurant just you know chatting
away or whatever
um and this random dude just came up to
me random Korean dude and I knew
something was kind of weird because he
kind of flagged me down yeah and then he
was like oh hey man how's it going he
kind of spoken like a slight Australian
british-esque accent but the kind where
it's like a bad impression right oh okay
and at first I thought it was a fan yeah
right because he just came up to me not
so non only yeah and so I responded like
I would if it was a fan I shook his hand
I was like yeah man how's it going you
know like how's your night being blah
blah blah and then randomly he just
points towards this building in the
distance and he goes I work there
I went
cool
uh didn't ask but I'm glad I'm glad
you're happy that you work at that
particular establishment that I am
unaware of and then he just started
asking me questions like oh where are
you guys from you know blah blah blah
and that's when I realized oh he's not a
fan he's just a random dude who just
stopped me and I guess just wanted to
start talking to me for some reason so
that that happened to me twice when I
was yeah I was in South like three days
as well yeah and people like I just
randomly obviously we look like tourists
and I think I don't know if it's normal
for locals to do this but especially I
felt like someone just wanted it felt
like someone just wanted to practice
their English right they saw a tourist
they were like all right boys it's time
and and unlike unlike you know Japanese
people where they're like very reserved
they're like you know can't talk to
random strangers don't do that don't
don't break people's uh social
boundaries Koreans are just like you
know what I'm gonna I'm just gonna
strike up a conversation and see where
it takes me honestly and I think the
only reason why he decided to start
talking to me in particular is because I
think he heard my accent and then he
mentioned to me that he lived in the UK
for a couple of years and that's how he
learned his English right and I was like
okay I mean good on you like you know
your your English is certainly better
than you know the average Korean that
I've talked to so far on this trip but
also it was at like 11 p.m on a side
street and my first instinct was this
guy's trying to [__] mug me
and I could see Aki's just like [__]
herself just being like get me the [__]
out of this conversation right now and
then I found a really weird when after
all of that just kind of Chit Chat
getting to know you know about him and
his supposed workplace yeah he was like
where are you staying
and then that's when the red flag went
up and I was like uh and I just I just
mentioned something yeah yeah yeah I'll
just mentioned some other hotels I'm
like oh it's like down there we gotta
get the train or whatever and he's like
okay do you want me to like take you to
that hotel
and I was like I'm good bro that's a no
from me dog I I know my way we've been
here for a couple of days it's all good
and so I I started to get really really
worried yeah luckily he like left me
alone after that he was just like okay
have a good night mate and I was like
yeah that didn't happen to me yeah I was
like yeah you too man and I just [__]
bolted across the road I'm like please
don't follow us but yeah that was I it
was it was scary but also I don't know
it was a little bit endearing right yeah
yeah you that is a situation that you
will Almost Never encounter in Japan
right especially if the Japanese person
is striking up the conversation yeah
that would never happen that would never
happen absolutely no especially in Tokyo
so yeah it's pretty it's happened a few
times outside of Tokyo but not in Tokyo
no no it's happened to me in like all
soccer and stuff right where the
stranger friendliness is a little bit
better but yeah never in Tokyo yeah I uh
going to Osaka I this is a random
question which I noticed because well I
also just recently went to on con uh on
Connor's RV trip which was Major success
congratulations bro congratulations
um yeah why do people on uh Osaka on the
escalator stand on the right hand side
and people in Tokyo stand on the
left-hand side what's up with that oh
that's uh so that's a West Japan versus
East Japan is it that's what they do
yeah yeah and people in Hokkaido stand
mostly in the middle what yeah did you
ever notice that do they really yeah I
feel like they don't that's like a thing
that they do who decided I think I've
been on an escalator
actually no that's an achievement I
actually don't think I have yeah but for
some reason I don't know who came up
with this rule but for the most part if
you live on East Tokyo you stand on the
left if you live in West Tokyo you stand
on the right I think this is just like a
little quirky thing that they wanted to
just keep I think and they were like
that's just that's our thing yeah
whereas like other places are like we
have uh I don't know we're we're more
alcoholic than you whereas yeah to Japan
they're like we stand on the other side
of the escalator and it's like what what
yeah I don't know yeah that's so it's
just some random piece of the thing that
I noticed when I went to Osaka but
that's how you can tell if someone is
from outside of the prefecture yeah yeah
right I feel like that's like the silent
way to out someone to be like oh he
doesn't belong here you're not from
around here the op we used to just copy
what everyone else is doing at all times
yeah everywhere pretty much and then
that way you can't go wrong then yeah I
don't even know which side is left or
right I still haven't figured that out
yeah you still have to do this thing
I don't even know what side of the road
they drive on here I just I just follow
the other cars like I don't know
did you notice in Seoul uh for you when
you went out later no well there's just
a lot more drunk people on the streets
holy [__] every corner I walked around
was like it was like Shibuya meltdown
but like every corner yeah I was I was
it shocked me so much not only that but
it was Shibuya meltdown at like 8 P.M
yeah right
into the restaurant and I just see a
dude asleep in the hedges on the side of
the road I'm like homeless or just very
very drunk at an 8pm on a Friday yeah I
was gonna say was it a weekday or just
uh was it so the first day we got there
was a weekday wow yeah but even still
it's like even on a weekend I'm like
damn these boys going hard like it's not
even that late and you're already like
this yeah that's one thing that
surprised me because I thought in Japan
you know there is a big drinking culture
here in Japan especially you know with
uh with workers and salarymen and
everything like that but in Korea I
think it's just on a whole nother level
oh yeah it's it's because Soju [__] you
up it's so much harder than anything
Japan they don't just [__] you up they
mix that [__] with beer man I know and I
know there's a word for it but it's like
it is you know tradition I think it's
called Devil's concoction because that's
what it shouldn't be called it is called
regret the next day that's the official
Korean translation hangover Speed Run
yeah because I don't know why like Soju
I think like unflavored soju that [__]
that that [__] tastes it's awful it's
like turpentine dude holy [__] it's
horrible it is it is I I cannot handle
that stuff it tastes too strong for me
for some reason most of the time you mix
some kind of spirit with a beer tastes
worse right for some reason Soju and
beer I don't know how they had this
magical concoction that it's the perfect
Spirit to have with beer but also it's
the most dangerous one because mixing
any spirit with beer is just like a
roadway to be regret hurts hearing that
they mix I know I know they mix it I've
tried it the Soju would be if I don't
like it you don't like it no I like my
beer being beer I'm kind of indifferent
to it like yeah maybe just because I'm a
Soju hater but
anything was so jumbling yeah it looks
like the go-to beer in like Seoul like
Casino Japan has Asahi in the UK yeah
terrible beers
um you can't remember there is yeah
there is there is one local Koreans it's
like the goat beer though yes the goat
it's I mean I wouldn't necessarily call
it the ghost like it's like the beer
that you drink if it's like
[Applause]
it tastes like very uh what's the word
it's yeah it's so inoffensive to
everyone yeah even if you're like not a
big beer person you're like well so he
doesn't have much going on yeah it's
just very light very easy to dress I
think Australia's my favorite out of out
of like the mass-produced worldwide
beers
like not not the best beer okay
obviously okay Germans Belgium's calm
the [__] down for a second I mean
obviously that Crown goes to Budweiser
as we've established but if you go into
a bar or Pub and you see something on
tap and it's just one of like you know
Carlsberg Asahi Heineken and all like
the normal ones I'll choose Asahi every
time oh yeah yeah that to me is like
it's the most refreshing band it's most
the most inoffensive as well
um but so yeah I don't rate Thai beer at
all that's that's just me I mean I mean
we had it and you guys had it and uh it
was all right I knew they didn't know
what was going on with beer when they
try to hand me a straw
I didn't trust them it can't be good you
know don't give me a straw what is that
what is a fruit loop yeah but like I
think the other thing that just got me
shocked while I was in Korea was just
man I I haven't weighed myself but I
definitely put on weight because I mean
for one I was eating so much more
because everything was delicious I'm
like too I'm like how do these Koreans
stay thin like it's insane like because
everything just seems so inherently bad
for you especially when you compare it
to like a lot of Japanese food I guess
it's the same in Japan though right like
you you can when you come into your
tourist you can easily eat everything
and it's like most of it's pretty bad
for you yeah but if you're living here
you can a lot more healthy stuff you
probably have way more kimchi in your
diet yeah yeah oh my God probably don't
eat fried chicken often yeah dude my
farts were smelling like kimchi that's
what I was eating like was there a
noticeable taste in the kimchi in Korea
compared to foreign
Korean kimchi over late Japanese kimchi
or like any anywhere else I've had it is
that like the the Cabbage just feels
fresher okay like even though it's weird
because it's fermented right so
technically it's not fresh but I don't
know it has like a certain like crunch
to it right okay that just feels nicer
to eat I think like a lot of kimchi I've
had especially in like Japanese like
yakiniko or wherever is like it can get
a little bit sloppy sometimes all right
and very like soupy yeah whereas I feel
with Korean kimchi they don't overdo it
with like the the sauce or whatever it
is right so it's it just feels lighter
to eat I I feel like that's more on like
the chef or whoever's fermenting the
kimchi and how much how much you uh
ferment it I had kimchi at every food
establishment I was in Korea and it was
all pretty unanimous with like the
freshness yeah so I was like okay well I
mean this is looking for the third
person this sounds like a placebo kind
of thing you know it's just like uh
normal kimchi Korean kimchi
maybe it was I don't know but in Korea I
mean it made my food experience that
much more enjoyable so I'll take it but
I also ate like way too much topogy
because like oh that's one of my [__]
favorites it's so nice it's heavy and
like God the first night I went to this
like food market and I got like this
full-on bowl of top boggy this thing
looked like it was sitting in a bowl of
lava like it was so much sauce in it was
red as hell so filling man it's so
feeling
and God my [__] was on fire the next
day but God damn was worth it it was so
goddamn good here's what I want to know
how was the airport in Korea
this is
I feel like you can judge your city
pretty pretty accurately on the the
quality of the airport really I feel
like it gives you an indication of what
to expect figure out every airport
you've been to I feel like it's very
reminiscent of the city as a whole right
maybe I don't know I'm in an airport
that feels wildly different to the city
I'm trying I'm trying to think right
because a lot of airports are very just
neutral my mind there's only like the
the big cities that stand out to me yeah
so like where we landed which was inshon
airport which is I guess like the main
two airports yeah there's there's a
number of airports that's all I think
but in Sean is kind of like inchon
reminded me of Narita okay where it was
like kind of outside of the city it was
like an hour and a half away from Seoul
Central City
um but it's the but that's where all the
international flights yeah that's the
major one yeah but it very much reminded
me of Narita in a lot of ways whereas
like very bong standard very gray simple
nothing like you know they're not going
like Avalon guard with the like they do
at Hunter right yeah yeah yeah I was
like yeah I mean it's it's fine it was
it was a possible airport I mean
anything compared to LAX right all right
so it's like as long as it's not LAX
level just keep me out of LAX and JFK
yeah
um yeah I just like making mental notes
of airports I go to like which ones do I
what's your favorite airport ever yeah
what dude I really want to go everywhere
Singapore is like Singapore's the goat
Singapore is the ghost I agree I really
want to go to that one yeah man not not
to Singapore just the airport
once I get to the airport I'm like I'm
good I'm going back I've been to
Singapore guys I want to go to the
cinema to get a better Southeast Asian
country right fellow Southeast Asians in
the in watching this as a Malaysian I
would agree Chinese it is
[Applause]
the fellow Southeast Asians I'm one of
you oh hello fellow selfies hello fellow
white people how are you today
um I don't know uh trying to think which
one's been I think Vancouver Airport's
okay
thank you was pretty nice yeah thank you
it was very nice I've never got Norfolk
Vancouver but I've laid over at
Vancouver airport it was quite nice yeah
I'm trying to remember which airports
have left an impression on me uh
Vancouver has one of the best designs of
like terminals I've seen it's got like a
very nice theme to it I think it's meant
to be like uh I don't know it's like all
wood I think it's supposed to be like
reminiscent like indigenous right groups
it's lovely I all I remember from
Vancouver is such a middle-aged men
conversation what's your favorite the
only thing I remember from Vancouver
airport is that on the way to
immigration there's this like massive
waterfall inside the actual lamp on I'm
like oh that's pretty like like you know
I think to all the airports I've been to
and I feel like they do kind of do a
very good job like mirroring the city
Vibes in in many ways like LAX is like
dysfunctional but you could pay a lot of
money to make problems go away yeah and
it's just a mess and a war zone the UK
is like kind of fun but also just a lot
of headaches which I feel like is the UK
what about Sydney airport Sydney airport
was great I had a great time you know
Good Vibes
so many like Sydney I've never seen
another airport do this uh Sydney
airport like on the way to go to the
passport check I've never seen so many
alcohol shots
and then you're like you go through like
all right another last chance and you're
about to go through like seriously now
yes you have you can buy four bottles
it's like tax for what are you doing and
then when you get through the the
passport thing it's like you'd be put in
your ticket to go through it's like
where is your four bottles of alcohol
yeah you didn't buy any are you done
yeah go back your mate they're like you
don't understand how expensive
yeah what are you doing
that's what everyone every Australian
complains about when they go abroad
they're like this the Bombay Sapphire is
this cheap so how expensive it is in
Australia a bottle of Bombay in
Australia is like 65 it's it's [__]
ridiculous that's why every time I come
back home my dad is like four bombays
mate that's all I need so not even that
good gym but it's just like pretty good
and it's like very good like consumer
gin I think yeah you get like fancy
craft [__] but yeah yeah I really liked
it in the airport but like I I didn't
know if I actually liked it or I was
just relieved because it was such a big
contrast from flying to LAX to Flying to
Sydney and I was just like oh my God a
pleasant experience at an airport okay
I've missed this so much I remember when
I went to uh I went to New Brunswick
airport in uh Canada New Brunswick is
like right right right East just before
Nova Scotia right which is a weird thing
as well because I didn't realize that
that even had its own time zone a normal
us one it's minus so the UK is zero
right New York is minus five typically
without East let's say ignore daylight
savings this one's minus three so it's
two hours ahead of New York because it
curves around like that and this airport
was so small the person who checked me
in then also helped like get the bags
off the belt and hand it to the people
picking them up like I checked in and
then I put my bags on and I saw the same
person go back and start helping like
move the bags around I had the exact
same thing I had the exact same
experience when I flew to yakushima yeah
and I was like oh because the plane
itself could fit maybe like 20 people in
it oh it's a tiny [__] biplane yeah
and we landed and as we were coming down
I saw this [__] crap Shack and I'm
like that's the airport
I've seen Apartments bigger than this
yeah the thing that sucks about getting
two hours early but for your flight for
that is that you get that two hours
early and you literally have nothing
yeah there's nothing to do anything you
go inside and there's just like a bench
that's it yeah literally and it was
freezing cold because it was in like
Canada yeah it was Winter I remember one
of the weirdest airports I've been to
well was back when I was a teenager uh
popular holiday spot for you know young
teenage Brits is a cavos which is like
one of the yeah exactly where is that uh
it's one of it's uh like an uh so isn't
it in Spain I think it's crazy oh yeah
oh that's one of the Greek Islands yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah okay
you know I
it's not the it's not my favorite
holiday in the world you know but as a
British teen you go there and you just
get [__] [__] face hammered every day
it's that kind of holiday yeah the
equivalent in Australia is Bali okay
is the only destination to go and just
get hammered as a teenager I don't
remember
I remember the passport check at that
time when I flew there was we landed and
we go into the airport and I'm waiting
for the passport check and everyone's
like all right bring your passports out
and there's one security dude no desk no
nothing just standing there and you're
literally just waving your part like
there's a group of people just waving
your passport as you like walk past him
and that was the passport check and I
was like what is going on right now
where's the National Security let's just
do going yep yeah yeah yeah yeah I've
had the hardest time getting into some
nightclubs I'm coming into this country
and all I'm doing is just flashing my
passport like what I don't know if it's
still like that but uh that's what it
was like when I when uh when I was 18.
Jesus Christ yeah I mean I think that
was uh yeah yeah I remember I went to
Greece and it was pretty much like they
were like all right yeah what are you
coming in yeah
I don't get paid enough to check your
passport this episode sponsored by boxer
what are you holding there Connor well
it's a boxer that looks magnificent tell
me all about it well Joey I thought
you'd never ask because box would
delivers the experience of tasting
authentic Japanese snacks candies and
tease sourced directly from Century old
small family businesses and their
mission is to empower Japan's
traditional stack makers by sharing
their authentic food and stories with
the world John what theme do we have
today all kind of the first Boxer you
get is called Seasons of Japan it's
basically boxer's greatest hits for all
of their snacks that everyone loves look
at all those snacks
what do I choose and after the seasons
of Japan box you'll get a new theme
every single month or I'm gonna try
these tomato these tomato flavors and
rice crackers I've had those before
those ones Big Mama crunchy flavorful
tomato I remember this one I uh binged
myself on the white strawberries
whenever these these comes in my boxy
boxes every time baby 10 out of 10. not
only that but every box who comes with
its own tea pairing as well this month
we have the organic genmae Chuck and
we've been living in Japan now for a
while and we never see snacks as unique
at your standard con beanies you get 15
off your first box of Japanese snack box
use Alco trash taste at boxu.com that's
b-o-k-s-u.com that is
b-o-k-k-s-u.com with code trash test for
the 15 off your first order but uh you
went on your RV trip I did yes four days
yeah four days 12 hours of live
streaming a day God damn yeah yeah long
time but I think it went really well
let's see what your hours in yeah
you know how it is uh yeah it was really
fun uh very stressful very very
stressful very tiring of course of
course you wake up one hour of prep and
then go live and then one hour of prep
and then sleep rinse and repeat Jesus
and sleeping in an RV is
sucks
oh it was a pretty big RV though right
like yeah you got the best bet as well
though I had the best badge but it still
sucks so what the [__] are you
complaining about you got the double bed
yeah I know it's only a double bed it's
not a queen listen it's like it's a
cushion it's a cushion okay and the and
so I rented like so when I uh rented
this RV you could you could take a bunch
of things you wanted to rent with it and
I rented like the sleeping bags and the
pillows yeah and I I mean you know I'm
not a picky guy right yeah I mean okay I
lie I'm a picture I'm a picky guy yeah
um but for this like when it's a video
shoot I'm kind of I'm like whatever gets
it done yes
whatever whatever we do to do like
you're not there for a holiday no no if
it's a holiday and and this happened I'd
be like excuse me
where is my king bed yeah I I would have
okay so we we rented the sleeping bag
pillow set we got this pillow and it's
literally just this like it's it's just
a floatable like device it would blow it
up yeah it's like a pool noodle yeah
it's fine it's fine but it's like I feel
bad when I'm asking like like uh I I got
Pete and um did I just joined me and I
feel bad when I'm like hey guys come
join me by the way you're gonna be on
camera for 13 hours and you have to
sleep on a on an air pillow yeah yeah
I'm sorry guys man we can buy real peels
no that's fine it's fine it just sucks
because you just want a real pillow
sometimes why don't you just like go to
like a donkey and get a like a cheap ass
pillow yeah pretty should have done that
yeah didn't have much time yeah I'm I'm
gonna out myself for a little bit I
didn't sleep on the other yeah he didn't
okay I think okay immersion ruin
immersion I know I know so I got there
on uh on the third day and I remember
like I had I had a [__] mission
getting to the RV on like the first day
myself
um and I remember you know at the end of
the third day everyone was [__]
knackered and you could tell right you
you can tell the difference between you
know dialus and Pete who I would say
have been creating content for like
unless
a shorter amount of time than I have
because I'm like when the cameras are
off I'm like okay we need to do a shoot
tomorrow I need to be well rested they
were being great mates and they'll be
like oh let's let's do the RV experience
it's you know we're fine with it we
don't need the pillow I got that and I
remember I remember asking so where am I
sleeping and they told me where I'm
sleeping and I measured it out and I'm
like I can't even I I was the tallest
one so I was like I can't even lay Flats
you know and I was like do we have a
pillow and they were like no
so I was like in my head I was planning
out okay am I am I how am I gonna am I
how am I gonna sleep am I gonna like
take my coat out use that as a pillow
luckily there was a that was the day
where there was like an extra like two
beds that they had booked for that day
yeah every day I put like a what an
extra a bunch of extra beds in the hotel
or whatever just because it was like all
right if somebody wants to I'm gonna be
like you have to sleep in the RV I'm
like yeah I'll do it because I feel like
it's my thing and I should yeah but
anyone else I'm like [__] it go sleep in
there yeah for sure yeah yeah yeah so
you know after the cameras had rolled
off it was like you know 10 30 or
something the staff were like everyone's
knackered and stuff like all right last
call is anyone going to sleep in the
Hotel La this is your last chance and I
turn over to a like uh Pete and
dinosaurs like are you gonna take the
bed and they were like nah man we gotta
stay here we're gonna stay here Peter
you stay you you take it to bed now I
gotta stay here man I'm like I'll be
honest guys I kind of want to sleep in
the bed tonight and we're we're on
camera tomorrow for like 13 hours
I've had enough shoots in my life that
uh because here's the thing I remember
when I first started like doing IRL
content you know I really wanted to get
involved and immersed and now like how
many years after trash Chase I'm like I
just want a good night's sleep event if
I know I'm making content you can say
that because you've experienced the
trash taste road trip oh yeah that's
that where like that gave me so much
knowledge into just how important a good
night's sleep is holy [__] I I think it
was because of the trash test road trip
where I was like I'm gonna be real
Connor I wanna bet tonight you know just
go get out of here yeah
have a good night
I mean I I would have done it if there
was no option available because that's
what I signed up for but I was like if
the options available amen I'm gonna
take it man I'm gonna take it I'm sorry
I'm sorry okay yes I'm weak-willed okay
yes I know I know okay this is fine yeah
I have to yeah I think what's important
to you on the stream yeah yeah exactly
right exactly uh but it was fun yeah it
was great it was a ton of planning a
[__] ton of planning to get it all to do
because we had to find like activities
to do every day yeah that was cool and
would be interesting and we had to make
sure that we'd get signal and if we
didn't figure out the solutions I like
uh yeah because I wanted to stream it in
basically 4K so because because twitch
doesn't let you stream in 4k because
um it's terrible in that sense and
doesn't let you do it I've I've
complained so many times I'm like twitch
please let me stream 4K but they say no
um so but you can like still stream in
4k and then down sample to 1080P and it
still looks great yeah yeah so I really
wanted to test out this 4K equipment and
test out a camera with a better
microphone uh to really try and and make
the IRL stuff feel more uh what's the
word uh upscale yeah I don't know like
more pretty much higher quality yeah
yeah like it feels more like a TV show
yeah where the camera doesn't stop
rolling for sure yeah yeah which has its
benefits and having sound size but
um and and you know it seemed pretty
possible you just need a [__] ton of
internet and good internet because you
need to you need like five to four times
the uh bandwidth of a normal IRL stream
yeah for a 4K stream so it's a lot a lot
more stuff going on right and it breaks
way more often so I you know I kind of
kind of was looking around I started
asking a bunch of people who knew all
this stuff better than me I was like
what camera is the best for this also
how do I do this and how do I literally
do everything so you go and ask someone
like hey what camera do I use then you'd
be like you go to the guy who knows how
the all the software works like Hey will
this camera work with this this guy told
me to get this camera he's like yeah I
mean theoretically
and then and then and then I need to oh
dude there's so many so many little
things that went wrong before I even
started the RV trip where I was like I
don't even know this is going to make
sense like
um the the this new thing came out
basically like all streamers have like
two ways uh of broadcasting there's
these two like boxes there's like a more
a cheaper more custom one that's harder
to use
um uh but the benefit is that you don't
have to pay like a monthly subscription
and then the one that most people use is
this one that you pay a monthly
subscription for yeah um and it's a bit
more expensive and has less kind of uh
what's the word like uh customization um
and and that that company that did that
one brought out a bigger one that could
do 4K so I was like okay this is let's
do it let's do it yeah and then it
turned out like to get it to work you
need to do a bunch of weird stuff that
was like what and then you and then you
need to connect two modems to One USB
thing yeah how do you connect two modems
to One USB where you need a USB splitter
yeah and then that doesn't work for some
reason and then I asked the company had
to get them I had to like speed dial the
company and be like hey how do I get
this to work in the in the guide it says
you can do this like oh no you need a
you need a specific cable that isn't
released yet I'm like what
what but then they're like oh we can
send you some though and I was like oh
cool but like how was I supposed to know
this yeah so luckily they sent me those
and they arrived in time yeah this whole
[__] headache this has been before
you even planned what we're doing you're
getting the RV getting how are we gonna
film this thing how are we gonna do it
basically headache after headache yeah
we got it to work though
um and it looked pretty damn good I
think the first part yeah like we we had
to get creative with some solutions so
we even bought like a starlink internet
um which uh [__] hell and to get that
to work remotely we had to I bought like
a giant power generator thing like uh
yeah
it's like a it's a it's a like a giant
giant battery that you charge and it
takes hours it's basically just a
generator at this point right it's a
generator basically uh and then you
basically like we we only we only empty
luckily thank God we only need to use it
like once or twice
um because it could get like way better
internet than any of the cell phone
towers could give us yeah but it's just
like you know you're trying to stream
and then you're like all right what's
the internet oh I got it [__] and then
you're on camera like okay okay and then
you're like all right can we can we can
we get the thing out and we hook it all
up and it's like you're just juggling so
many things and you're constantly
checking all the text working uh and
then there's other stuff like there's a
we have the tracker on the map shows you
where I am but I have to do that as well
so it's like you're juggling just like
five thousand seven this is why like as
much as I want to try more IRL streams
I'm just so scared to because I did not
want to deal with that stress yeah it
sounds like a [__] nightmare but you
can just hire me now I'll do it for you
it's like I I try to show these guys how
it all works uh and like with people who
I bring along but it's so tough to
explain people how a lot of this stuff
works and if it breaks how to fix it
yeah yeah so it's still like if
something breaks more often not it's
like all right guys gone entertain I'm
gonna go and fix everything real quick
right
um and it's very frustrating but I think
it's worth it in the long run like it's
a ton of stress and it's a ton of
anxiety
um about if it's if it's working but I
think
um I think the results speak for
themselves it looked amazing yeah what
activities
I'm just too busy talking about the tech
yeah that's the punishment
um yeah I was like but the Dolphins
though the Dolphins yeah we went um so
day one we did um we so we started in um
we picked up the RV in Shino Osaka yeah
which is the bullet train stop in Osaka
we drove to Allergy and then we started
there and so day one was just all of
Hawaii Island which is beautiful it's a
stunning Island that connects uh
Mainland Japan to Chicago and it's also
a weird [__] yeah we have so much
touristy stuff though like if you're a
tourist you shouldn't sleep on Elijah
Island it's so cool they have so much uh
support for English-speaking tourists as
well and they have a [__] ton of stuff
yeah so much anime stuff on awaji island
as well yeah they're the Naruto theme
park and the Hello Kitty hotel I think
yeah it's all there yeah and a bunch of
other just like why is this so much yeah
uh you know one of the biggest
challenges of doing IRL
um normally is getting permission yeah
uh and we had such a big rig where there
was no way we could like you know kind
of go in sneak around yeah but like hope
that it would just kind of be okay like
we had such a big rig that like we had
to get in contact with everywhere and
arrange everything beforehand yeah um so
the career in it now yeah yeah right
right 100 apparently I should get a
[__] career yeah like that's what I
should have been doing but luckily like
everything we've got permission for it
was all chill and it was great so day
one we did um we uh did a Zen experience
in this like Bond villain headquarters
conveniently that's not a day I was
there yeah so you know
we kind of made a fun challenge out of
everything yeah and it was like dude
this thing was sick you guys would love
it God would love it yeah it was
literally just this wooden a beautiful
wooden structure that just extends over
this view of like a bunch of trees and a
bunch of landscapes in awaji and you can
just meditate with a professional I
guess zen master oh that's a little bit
the woman that was there there was a
Thai woman yeah because I I saw I saw
the clip of like the woman introducing
you and I was like I think I hear a Thai
accent yeah yeah it wouldn't surprise me
I think his name was uh Bilal UH no the
woman no the guy
who is uh from Virginia who had trained
trained with uh you know the most Zen
Place uh I think like masters of
meditation in in Japan but I think
they're originally from India but so he
learned everything in Japanese
I think an Indian guy I think so yeah
Marshall again but he he basically just
you know went through it and he was
awesome he was up for the banter even
though we were kind of you know trying
to make a joke or two while meditating
yeah it was so much fun it was great and
then and then we went to do uh kawara
tiles which we've done before yeah yeah
uh but then I I beat my record and I
beat their their local record in that oh
yeah I saw that clip man yeah that was
so fun that place was great they they
had costumes there was it was literally
like this this like John Wick or kind of
it was so reminiscent of like martial
arts fight scenes the bottom floor of
this this uh building it was literally
the factory but it looked like a set
piece of like like an old boy or
something yeah yeah like a factory
because it looked like it didn't look
like a real factory it looked like a
factory in a movie yeah um and then just
above this Factory was a kawara
experience where you go and smash them
oh yeah and uh I managed to break 34
tiles hey which is [__] insane I
didn't think I could do it and then just
yeah I was like oh did you like kind of
build yourself up to that yeah we did um
we did 20 and we've been there for about
two hours I think at that point we were
kind of like all right we should wrap it
up and I thought just for fun let's just
let's just go to 34 because we've gone
up by five I was like just add 14.
because the record was 33. right I was
like [__] it up I'll beat it but
obviously I didn't think I was gonna
beat it but I thought it'd be visually
pretty funny yeah yeah
um and somehow smashed it yeah you got
it it was the Bruce Lee costume that
gave you the power yeah
and then yeah I did it and that was fun
and then we did like barbecuing and then
day two we did um we went from albuji
Island all the way over
um to Chicago the northern part and then
went to okayama above just above okay
I'm Camp there for the night oh so you
went through the uh setonaikai like
driving trail that we did the cycling
special I'll go through that side
right and we drove past like takamatsu
and go outside yeah so we did like
dolphin training and dolphin swimming
Dolphins they're so cute they're so cute
dude and all the staff are so kind and
they were so nice and you know it seemed
like they really were like obsessed with
those Dolphins it seemed like they
really loved it yeah
um it was fun man damn Dolphins [__]
did they did they meet the hype do
dolphins meet the hype the dolphin hype
I'm still I'm still curious about
dolphins
one too many times yeah yeah he's made
me scared of dolphins yeah they were
cute though they were cute they're so
incredibly smart though like oh yeah oh
it shows oh yeah yeah yeah I I'm pretty
sure they're smarter than me
very intelligent creatures yeah yeah and
it was nice and the uh that whole
everything we feel like because I've
I've like like rubber
they look like they're made around yeah
yeah they like rub they feel like rubber
honestly like Smooth rubber I don't know
how to describe it it's a very it's very
odd yeah yeah like a wet rubber yeah and
that was so cool to stream because the
clips of it look awesome like the the
quality of it considering we're just on
a pier in the ocean yeah and we're
pretty like far out from the coast yeah
yeah and it's really cool like this so
it looks awesome yeah and again I I just
my whole thing is that like originally
for me this whole which sounds so weird
to say like this whole RV's trip was
kind of like a test in my mind to see if
this could work and you know now that I
see that it went really well I kind of
want to try and do it again but maybe
bigger and see how I can improve it yeah
um make it more more easy on everyone
involved as well so yeah it's not
exhausted all the time uh but yeah the
dolphin thing was great that day
and they they told us about dolphins
they gave us a little quiz about how to
what did you learn
how to tell between a male and a female
dolphin didn't know that oh okay didn't
know that so the one that has the
massive [__]
is the male they have more lines I guess
or spaces where maybe baby dolphins
would come out of and where they would
do the Deeds right um uh that's the
difference I found out they taught us
not to put trash in the ocean been doing
that anyway
I've been on a good run with that yeah
yeah then we went to a went to this open
air theater uh uh near the dolphin place
and do this this open air theater is
sick like as in like what like like a
drive-in theater or something what's the
official what's the like the actual name
Amphitheater yeah oh okay it's like and
if you it's like this stunning theater
and it's behind it is the ocean oh wow
if you stand in this one specific spot
your voice like completely resonates so
loudly that it's it's like a megaphone
oh you're just talking right only in
this one specific spot you have to stand
there if you and you move one step and
then you sound normal and you step step
and say exact spot and it's like boom
it's like it's like just gets like
absolutely like it's insane physics yeah
it's like what the [__] how how do they
do that I didn't I know it's physics but
like it was so impressive that just a
volume difference yeah yeah it's blew my
mind we had a little yeah it went really
well Pete won the township jokes of
course you'd existence
yeah and then we had a we had a barbecue
uh while it was snowing in the middle of
nowhere where God eventually came and
joined us yeah like 1am after the stream
ended yeah but we were in the middle of
I don't even know we didn't even use the
starlink that night but we had we had
really good signal in the middle of the
mountains in no City we were like an
hour away from any City I have no idea
how we had any signal I don't know one
thing that surprised me on the road trip
was you you you when you're constantly
on the air sometimes you go to a point
it's open roads can't nothing to block
the signal and it just like loses
connection yeah and then you go in like
a mile long tunnel and it's just like
perfect signal all the way through and
I'm like what this is so random man how
does this work I should know because I'm
an electronic engineer but I'm just like
how are we having signal right now it's
cell phone towers and also depends on
which provider they are because which
Sims I have right but I have multiple
different Sims that do they should cover
everything but yeah it really depends um
certain areas should have just nothing
yeah but the first day was pretty tough
I think there was not a lot on a waaju
surprisingly
um and the third day we did which can't
joined us before we did uh the golf golf
driving range and I like this was the
first time I'd been on a driving range
or like picked up a golf club since I
was I think like 18 17. it's so much fun
I told you oh I've been telling you boys
that we should go to Gold I missed the
longest time so much I missed it so it's
gone until you hit the driving range
where you're like why is this fun yeah
so yeah we did that and we did a
competition see who could hit it the
furthest yeah I won you won you won I
got one very good shot that's all you
need dude it was so fun I want to go
driving range more yeah and then we did
um what else we do that day I forgot uh
we did a sand surfing yeah we're in San
serving totally yeah that was fun we
went back to the uh ghost town that is
I drove past the industrial area I'm
like don't look at that don't look at
that all right look at the Sand Dunes
yeah which uh I think looks even more
like the the weather conditions are just
the color what looks even better than
when we went there on our road trip
special cameras we were using for this
livestream were better than the cameras
we filmed fashion right so it looks like
it looks better live which is insane
yeah and I didn't I also didn't know if
totally was gonna have internet yeah um
but yeah totally is great internet as
well so fun fact there you go yeah I
don't know are you so we were in the it
looks insane on the stream we're just in
the in the middle of a desert streaming
yeah it's just like what what the [__]
and then we're going down these Hills
and it looks great dude it like it looks
so underwhelming on camera but it was
kind of scary going down these because
you're going pretty fast and sand I mean
I didn't fall so I can't yeah it
probably hurts I imagine you fell on
your wrist I fell on my wrist once okay
so I'll say it right now Sun surfing
that's kind of mad it was kind of it was
kind of a Mad experience yeah because
you you you just go down and you can't
do Hills that are super crazy because I
guess if you get too fast yeah falling
would be pretty and you can't you can't
turn either we weren't given any
instructions so how I described it
um Sansa thing was basically felt like a
tutorial level for snowboarding because
I I remember with bigger consequences
yeah basically you fall it hurts a
little bit more
um but essentially you go up to the hill
and uh I remember we had an instructor
there and uh I Was preparing myself for
the instructions to start and the
instructions were uh so don't fall yeah
yeah that's I was like don't try to turn
you're just going straight just uh don't
fall and that was the instructions and
it was like okay go you might as well
have just like been on a sled then at
that point actually he told us before we
started he was like if you think this is
going to be like snowboarding you're
gonna fail yeah and I was and I was like
what how can be it wasn't that hard
actually he was he was capping yeah he's
like snowboarding yeah um you just have
to balance the same way yeah yeah but
also all he said was um he'll said it
might be too hard so he brought sleds as
well so which was kind of worrying so I
was like oh that's not good too hard
it's not gonna hurt themselves so he
just gave her the helmet he said bend
your knees and then just go that was all
yep wow he pushed us yeah yeah and then
he goes oh by the way 10 year olds can
do this
like rub it in
pretty nice
um but yeah I mean it was kind of it was
like I said it was kind of like
snowboarding except you couldn't do
anything but go straight so essentially
you just kind of had to learn how to
balance going down a hill pretty fast
and I'd forgotten like it's been a while
since the last snowboarded and I'd
forgotten basically everything I got
told when I first started snowboarding
because I remember going somewhere
snowboarding for the first time with the
boys and the first thing they told me
was when you fall don't put your hands
out you gotta you know put your hands in
and I'd for some reason my mind was just
like sounds different Sans totally I'll
go straight through it yeah so that is
totally different than snow I don't I
don't have to worry about sand uh and I
the first time I felt I put my hand out
and it wasn't even like that big of a
fall I was going nowhere near as fast as
I was going when I was like snowboarding
but I just had like a little bit and my
wrist uh hit my wrist and I was you that
I had that immediate moment where I was
like oh that that felt bad that felt bad
I was like okay it's not broken I might
to sprained it luckily I didn't spray in
it but I had a big wake-up cool very
very fast uh falling on Sand uh sand
surfing the full it might not be as hard
as snowboarding but the four definitely
hurts more and uh luckily I wasn't the
one who ate the most [__] probably died
yesterday oh my God I felt so bad yeah
he he would nail it going down and the
moment like the hill went from this to
kind of like this yeah yeah just kind of
lost his balance every time and face
planted I felt so bad for him he just
kept getting beaten up Jesus yeah he hit
a few balls that looked pretty painful
oh my God but he powered through it yeah
it was fun but it was kind of like it
was very much like oh that's it yeah
like it was like oh that's all we could
do yeah like I feel like it sucks I mean
it was it was definitely I think it was
still like a fun place to check out and
it I think it's like we we hit like
every kind of scenery like we went from
like beautiful stunning green Islands to
snow to Desert yeah and back to Osaka it
was kind of like it covered everything
and then um we did that and then we
played video
because we play games in the RV which is
really fun actually yeah break the ice
is a great game yeah you kind of
introduced me to break the ice was like
this game no it's like a little thing
where it's like a penguin in the middle
and a bunch of hexagons yes
so good it's such a good game when
everyone's kind of hype and ready and
you have like punishments and yeah it
was so good it's kind of like that mini
game from four guys the one with the
hexagons except you have to hit them
yeah but you you have to hit them such a
good game there's so many good clips
from it and it was just a fun it was
such a good fun yeah board game I think
as as much as like you guys did these
like amazing things on the RV strip uh I
think my favorite clip to be both out of
it was when you asked didus one Milos
[Music]
thank you to the guy in Australia who
got asked with that because that's that
that one that trained us to get someone
else it's our new favorite yeah it's my
new favorite as a Southeast Asian that's
my new favorite because we we [__]
love Milo in Southeast Asia you know
that's that's our chocolate of choice
yeah you don't like it no oh
oh yeah and I was like what
yeah yeah is it much better than Nesquik
or is it oh hell yeah oh yeah yeah oh
yeah oh yeah Australia's the same we
[__] love our mileage yeah it's so
good there's so it was good it seems
like there was a lot of good good Clips
in the car and you know it's more of a
podcast when it's in the car that's back
to the activities yeah yeah the board
games are really fun that was one of my
favorite aspects to it yeah I'm just
playing playing dumbled games and just
just everyone everyone has their own
rules to everything that sounds
Django is just like what are the rules
of Jenga because we just kind of like
made it up as we go there's like a
million the Only Rule that was secret
was top three layers can't touch top yes
that's the only sacred touch it you have
to move it was the one yeah you have to
use one hand only right that's another
one but I don't know if it's an official
rule I swear people just make up rules
for gang and be like yeah let's just
make it a billion times harder than it
actually is supposed to be yeah like we
had we had this one moment where I swear
this isn't allowed but we had to run
with the one hand thing yeah and Connor
uses one hand to be basically change the
entire structural Integrity of this
Tower it was it went from like a Jenga
Tower to the Leaning Tower of Pisa and
he was just like he was just like it I
was getting it out my finger while kind
of holding the rest of them
so illegal right now because it was like
what sucked is that we were like four
turns in and this one block wouldn't
move that's the point I was like are we
really gonna end this game in four turns
that's so bad yeah but how is that any
different to like grabbing with one and
then using your other hand to just hold
the entire thing in place I mean like
honestly Django should always get to
that point in my mind where like you
holding it makes no difference to like
like if I like it gets to the point
where me holding it she's gonna make it
worse you know yeah because it gets so
[__] the tower is like yeah holding it
is actually a disadvantage I don't know
that's just me maybe I'm maybe I'm I'm
trolling it wrong house rules RV rules
and it was like it was like snowing
outside and we had the we had the
because the connection was kind of we
had like the starlink on a table outside
of the van and connected to this this
generator and then we're just using that
internet and that was like saving the
stream way better because we again we
were in the middle of nowhere again
um and that saved it and then the last
day we did uh Airsoft so that was
survival so much fun yeah that was my
first time Airsoft doing it yeah me too
that that lived up to the hype yeah I
want to go again now like it was fun I I
actually I think I found it funner than
paintballing yeah well it hurts a little
less it hurts a little less and the guns
just look cooler as well yeah you know
you know really like reloading uh uh
airsoft gun actually feels like you know
more similar to reloading a real gun
rather than just [__] like yeah
scoring a bunch of uh paintballs into
into the gun yeah that was fun we did we
were like again we had to like move the
starlink around to get into that uh
because the bitrate was terrible there
it was such bad internet because
obviously it's an airsoft field it's in
the middle of nowhere right yeah um
hey you guys said it holds less than a
paintball it does hurt less I mean this
one [__] hurt this one yeah I was
about to say like the scars there's
there's one red dot on Connor's forehead
that I I uh that I did yeah
[Music]
but like yeah if you get hit in the head
or the neck I feel like that's where it
[__] my legs hurt so much because we
we're in a course where it was just like
a bunch of like parts cars you know it's
like the car park kind of area first
thing Titus says was like Oh I thought
these were real cars so I tried not to
like shoot them and then like they had
broken windows but unfortunately do you
remember that yeah I couldn't believe
you said the average car park in Maine
average Ohio car block right
um but yeah like unfortunately being
tall was a huge disadvantage in this one
because uh if I just like poked if I
just poked my head out I would instantly
get headshot it was actually really easy
to be quite accurate on the uh on the
airsoft it was like surprisingly
accurate because yeah because I got a
few headshots from like a distance you
got so many shots from the distances
yeah I got a lot of head shots for
instance especially on dieters that's an
FPS player yeah player Advantage because
I realized like when you're aiming it
like obviously I'm not like cracked at
aiming air shocks I haven't played it
but like you shoot and unlike paintball
the airsoft bullet always goes the exact
same like trajectory unless yeah so all
you do is like and you can see where
it's going then just kick like yeah
adjusting and then you can pretty much
get it so that like if they poke their
head at all you can just get there yeah
right right yeah and you can just
slightly adjust so I just kept doing
that and I I kept getting died as I felt
so bad I shot them so many times
um next time I see him his face is just
gonna be like [__] well luckily he was
running away he was running a thick hat
so like his face was totally covered
yeah uh he had the one that covered his
ears too so it was like he was oh that
was fine he was ready
yeah it was really fun and we had like
uh unfortunately the camera had to go
around with us and he would get shot
sometimes because he was just going
around it was it looked awesome it
looked like an FPS yeah and again it was
like great quality like 4K in the middle
of nowhere yeah and then we changed povs
where he there was an area where you
could go above and you could look down
oh wow camera like it was kind of like
uh oh like bird eye view of the whole
yeah like no clipping yeah yeah it was
like such a cool stream and we had such
fun with it and yeah we we got great we
had this one game where I just could not
find Pete and Pete just P clipped into
another map right there there was like
this indoor this this indoor stage right
that was like very like very narrow
corridors and Pete spent like whole five
minutes in this outdoor map and he
didn't even know he was in a different
way we didn't know he was in a different
area like we didn't know that bro
clipped out to a different [__] stage
man
um but yeah like it it hurts a lot less
than paintball like paintball I feel
like you can still very like even if
you're wearing like thick clothes you
can still kind of feel it oh yeah
um this one unless you get shot like
directly on the skin it doesn't it it
doesn't really hurt that much yeah
um have you been painting paintballing
before I've been paintballing before
I've never been airsofting right and
I've been shot directly with a paintball
before and it sounds like a very Aussie
thing yeah yeah yeah as punished as
punishment for ever got the least amount
of points you have to get shot directly
in the stomach or the paintball and I
had that a couple of times and I was
left with like literal holes in my
stomach the bruises you get from
paintballing oh it hurts so much holy
[__] paintballing feels more like you're
just trying to avoid getting killed and
yeah uh Airsoft felt more kind of
because it didn't hurt as much you kind
of felt more fun yeah yeah exactly uh
but yeah I mean I do enjoy the
adrenaline aspect of paintball where
you're like I just don't get shot yeah
but a paintball is like valorant and uh
Airsoft is more like cod I would say
yeah right because because you know you
do not want to get shot in paintball you
know yeah you're like it's one show kill
if I'm getting shot I'm [__] out man
but with air stuff you're like I can I
can run I can run this I can run and go
don't do circles
yeah you would just run around corners
because you knew that if you got shot it
wasn't like the end of the world yeah
yeah it's like well I'm gonna have a
bruise if I get shot yeah it's actually
like this thing's gonna go I have to
think about wow what's happening
um man yeah no I'm such a fan of extreme
then we just drove back and ended it and
that was like 40 hours of streaming hell
yeah how's it being live for like that
long
um it's it's okay for me uh I mean he's
done sabbathons before so yeah I'm okay
with it but like man doing it and
driving is tough like driving is taxing
mentally anyway and then trying to also
be like good like conversing while
driving is hard yeah which is why it's
great to have uh you know you and Pete
and die yeah the real question was how
was it for you because you're probably
not used to that I was actually like
pretty fine with it uh you've gotten
really good at it I I think after the uh
24-hour charity stream we did that that
was like hard mode for me and then
everything afterwards was uh pretty
pretty like pretty easy because I
remember like I think Darius and Pete
they were telling me like the second day
was like tough yeah to like make sure
there was no dead air uh
anytime for like 13 hours right yeah
um so like they were really happy I
tried to like put as much of the
pressure off as possible
um but yeah it's just kind of like I
said after you like survived 24 hours of
sleep deprivation then just like
constantly talking I Feel Like Anything
anything's possible yeah nothing's
possible afterwards that's fair but yeah
I wouldn't want to do when I'm driving
because I want to be zoned out when I'm
driving you know yeah yeah I mean
especially when I because I you know
it's my first time ever driving a car
that big I think that's literally like
the limit of what the license allows in
Japan anything after that is just a
truck anything after that after you get
a different license yeah yeah there's
even like certain RVs I can't drive for
like I have to drive the smaller RVs and
the lighter ones right yeah uh because I
wanted to get a different RV initially
but it was slightly too heavy
um so I had to I had to get this one
um which is fine but it was really fun
to drive it like it was um because the
difference between like a car and an RV
is an RV you you're kind of like deeper
way more forward in the the RV so you're
like there's pretty much no distance
between your feet and where the car ends
so you you can really clearly see where
where the car is like everywhere or it's
like with a long with a normal car
that's kind of like got a bigger uh
front it's like it's way harder to
figure out where the [__] the front of
the car is yeah especially like the that
corner or I guess feed America be that
corner
um so I'm not words
um but it was fun though because you get
like this panoramic view of the road
because you have these giant Windows to
all sides of you that you can see yeah
and these giant mirrors and this the
dash cam the the yeah the behind you Cam
like the rear view cam is like on this
big screen it's really fun to drive yeah
scary on some roads but I got I think I
got pretty good at driving it by the end
yeah um I knew how to look like a proper
trucker yeah yeah you had fully fully
embraced that role
the trucker had you needed the Red Bull
and the pack of cigarettes one of my
favorite like out of context screenshots
was like here it was when Connor was
driving and this uh the stream had
glitched so it looked like he just
removed his chin so it just gave Connor
like a [__] leafy chin way it was
just like no Chin Connor
chocolate corner
I'll probably do another one at some
point in the future I'll probably figure
out how to make it better yeah for sure
there's definitely ways it can be
improved what do you think about how you
can improve it
um I think having either uh another
additional person during the whole time
will rotate out more people
um is definitely a way to kind of make
sure that everyone can be more energetic
because it's it's demanding like yeah 13
hours every day is pretty tough for most
people yeah even like streamers
especially when you're doing stuff
Outdoors as well and you know you're
actually getting physical right yeah it
can be pretty demanding
um probably I don't know maybe I feel
like I'd have to stay in the RV but I
wouldn't make other people stay in the
RV I feel like did you stay in a hotel
is so much better because also like
showering was annoying like getting oh
yeah hot water was a commodity yeah I
don't think we had we had like no hot
water like any time like all the
campsites had freezing water yeah it was
just so cold it sucked so much
um definitely gotta find someone who
maybe understands the bag and the
streaming stuff more so you're not the
only table because it's like you know we
start this like the the morning prep is
like I wake up I have to get all this
bag stuff ready and stuff and it's like
well man I I wish I could just hour it's
on the camera and we're going right but
it's like I have to get it already you
have to make sure everything's charged
make sure it's all working right and
then when you go to bed when the stream
ends sorry I have to unplug everything
make sure everything everyone knows what
to charge what and just get everything
ready before I can start going to bed
yeah so it's kind of tough I'm just
trying to think of how I can make it
better but it's really really fun really
successful I want to do it again oh yeah
yeah you guys got any plans coming up no
no no plans nothing Well no I I have a
I'm doing the cycling thing again yeah
what are you announcing that is by the
time this episode is out are you are you
going to have announced that I think
it'll be done no it'll be like basically
done oh [__] it'll be like I think
because this is like tell us all about
it it's like a month from now right yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah this is like yeah
this is like coming out halfway I think
like near the end of it yeah okay so I'm
doing another one of those yeah because
I remember you saying we finished the RV
trip and Connor's like yeah okay time to
start planning my next event and I was
like [__] hell Corner calm the [__]
down stay inside for a bit play some
video games man stop touching girls yeah
I want to go outside more
too much grass man too much grass I want
to go outside man you're an outdoorsy
person now oh no I just yeah I like
going outside and doing things yeah also
be like disgusting yeah yeah you know I
also want to uh do more things for
charity as well this year um and that's
one thing I really want to do and I
hopefully have another event in future
that we can do for charity yeah um yes I
just want to do more cool things like
I'm not really interested about I don't
know working from uh working in my
stream setup and doing that a bunch
because you know I still want to do that
but yeah I think my real passion is just
trying to do fun things and how can I
make it engaging yeah I'm I'm very very
excited because by the time this
episode's out I'm gonna be back in
Thailand that wasn't like I didn't
originally plan for that but I think
after uh you know after our last trip
where we all went to Thailand and we
were only there for a week I just I I
didn't realize how much I missed being
back in like my home country I miss
being in Thailand holy [__] yeah I just
I just wanted to like I just wanted to
because like when we last went back to
Thailand it was like you know busy busy
busy every single day yeah we had
something going on and it was you know
taking care of everyone coming and I was
just like I just wanna I wanna last year
was so [__] busy I just won a month
where I could just chill out and just
maybe do nothing but just enjoy the sun
enjoy the nice weather and just [__]
chill out and I was just like I was
thinking to myself how long has it been
since I last had that I literally cannot
remember since the beginning of trash
taste I think I feel like even just like
this year January and February we've
done more just like these past two
months than like six months last year
yeah it's just like I I keep I keep
waking up and looking at my calendar I'm
like how is it still February it feels
like I've been doing [__] for like six
months yeah it's just so jam-packed but
I mean we do it to ourselves so it's
yeah exactly like being busy I like
being busy as well I also like relaxing
yeah I do I don't know it's weird like I
feel like I enjoy uh okay question when
you like work a lot how much how many
days or or even a day or like how much
time do you need to mentally kind of
like have a reset
like per week or
uh I try and give myself at least one or
two days what's the ratio what's the
ratio of like work to like break that
you can do
um you guys are in sync yeah that was
like the brain cell far here
oh I don't know for me it's it's it's
weird right because I can I have these
like I it's either one mindset or the
other and I find it really hard to find
a balancing Middle Ground I don't know
if that makes any sense but there would
be like in time months where I'm like
grinding every day I've got something
going on every day and then like I've
got this like kind of like you know my
mind's just like constantly busy I gotta
do something and then there have been
points where I've had a week off and
I've like it's taken me just a few days
just to get used to having nothing to do
but like once my mindset switches it
also takes effort to get back into like
the grinding mindset as well oh the best
analogy I could uh the best analogy I
can think of is uh remember back in like
University College days where you had
like exam season right yeah and every
single day for like a month oh yeah it
would be you'd be studying for exams or
yeah two months you'd be studying for
exams and you'd be taking exams you'd
just be you know every day you'd wake up
open a textbook study until you sleep
and just piss yourselves because you're
like [__] I'm gonna fill out this
example right but I've got to get this
[__] done and the only thing you could
think of is I'm so [__] excited for
when this is over I'm gonna do so much
I'm gonna do so [__] much you're
you're like every day you open your book
you look at your steam library and
you're like one day one day that day
when this exam over I'm gonna get just
slowly correct your monitor yeah yeah
yeah I'm almost there
there and then you get to the last day
you finish the exam you're like I'm
[__] done holy [__] I feel so good
what do I do now yeah
like that that's that's my that's my
life now where it's like I get I have
this like month where it's entirely
booked out and then I get to the end of
that month uh and which it's slowly
coming up now because I I packed myself
in February I gave myself some time off
to chill out in Thailand
um and then I finished all my work
and then uh I remember I was like I
didn't know what I wanted to do so what
I ended up doing was uh helping my mates
actually so so instead of taking a
holiday I ended up helping Sydney film
uh helping helping Connor with his RV
trip and everything and then I just I
just realized I just ended up filling up
my schedule doing other things yeah
instead of taking a break which is why
which is why I felt like if I take a
break the country
to actually stop now yeah like I can't
do anything if I'm in a different
country right that's it is the ultimate
like sorry man I'm busy yeah sorry man
in a different country yeah I don't know
man I I I I I recently I appreciate I
said listen dresses right I bought this
really [__] nice coffee machine it
was way too much money but yeah it's
been uh you've reached that age well
you've reached that age where like
you're like my highlight right now is I
bought a new car dude honestly true and
it's made my mornings so much just to
have a lovely ritual where I hit I put
the beans in I grind the beans and I
just it's so nice it's so nice I steamed
the milk myself as well and I'm like
dude this is great and just so like for
me I for now like just having if I have
like a little lost like a lion I say
lion but like yeah if I can get like a
nice little relaxing morning where I can
kind of have an hour an hour and a half
to kind of chill out if I have to do
something yeah dude that's like I can
reset like that yeah that for me is
enough because then I get to make this
coffee I get to have a really nice chill
morning yeah and then I can start doing
my stuff yeah I think it says a lot but
you know after everything we've talked
about after like all the exciting things
you've done uh off camera are like the
most passionate I've ever seen Connor
recently it wasn't like being excited
for the RV trip or anything it's talking
about his [__] because coffee machine
like I remember coming to your house and
you're like yo you're gonna see my
coffee machine I try try a bit of the
coffee come on let me tell you about my
mornings now we've literally gotten to
that point because like I I recently
bought like a new vacuum cleaner like a
couple of days ago I got the latest
Dyson one I've never been that excited
in my last years I'm like oh oh this is
this is not I keep trying this ass oh
look at the the green laser that shows
you the [__] on the green laser it also
has like the little monsters on the back
that shows you the different particles
that you sucked up what's that thing
yeah so like the floor looks clean but
then this laser when it points at the
Floor shows you all the [__] yeah it's
kind of scary and it gives you a
percentage of like house dust and like
uh other specs and like what's in the
shoot yeah it tells you what's in the
[__] I'm like oh okay I got a little bit
of more house stuff today all right
let's go dude I should make some
overpriced garbage but I will say
they're vacuums very good oh yeah uh
they should they should keep doing that
yeah I mean they are but yeah no I mean
it's great because like I also get to
like I also get to like uh go to like I
have a there's a local coffee store near
me that just just does beans uh and I I
love going there I love beans I love
going there I love talking to the the
elderly couple that runs it and just
saying like man you know I like this
means that you gave me so yeah
I like these ones it's nice it's like my
whole experience then I get excited to
try the new blend that I bought this is
great it's like a hot it's like a nice
like whole chain of just every part of
it makes me feel feel like more of an
adult more like I don't know just taking
care of myself just having a nice coffee
even though now I I probably drink an
unhealthy amount of coffee yeah more so
uh it's hard because I have to I have to
I have to pull back a little bit now
yeah yeah because like day one dude it
was like dude I had like nine coffees I
couldn't stop it's so good it was so
good you had nine coffees let me
highball it was pretty like uh
exaggerating sorry I said drug addicts
it was like five it was still too much
but yo yo I had five hits when I first
tried them it was a good stuff it was
still it was still too much it was it
was a lot but it was great and so now
I'm trying to keep it two a day look at
us man getting excited for coffee
machines
again I think you know it's like I've
gone to that point I get it now like I I
you know because when people want you
know that whole thing people do
sometimes this always happens every like
every time on the internet after like a
few months where like there'll be that
article that's like uh no people people
on uh people aren't broke they're just
spending it on the wrong things and it's
like dude sometimes that little thing
makes someone's so happy oh yes it is
why would you say that stuff like that
yes people do frivolously spend or
sometimes but sometimes you need those
little things it is like just get you
through the day like sometimes you have
a rough day you have a you have a rough
schedule coming up you've got a packed
work week yeah and just having that
maybe having that milkshake having that
McDonald's something are you buying that
one silly thing you shouldn't have
bought just just got you through that I
I had that recently because I bought a
[__] growth coaster controller okay
okay
so happy yeah Joey will be the guy who's
like I bought a giant trampoline and
we're like sure you don't have a
backyard he's like I'll make it work
I'll find one I'll find a backyard but I
can put it in Jerry's like um Joey's
like I bought one out of ten thousand
Pink Floyd signed out yeah I'm like all
right dude I wish
I [__] wish yeah yeah I ordered this
[__] like uh custom-made like Groove
coaster yeah that like can can connect
to your computer just like simple USB
you can also play it on the switch as
well yeah not on stream yet but I've
been playing it mostly off stream just
because
I'll get to it eventually but just every
morning it's just like a ritual now
where I'm like
I got an hour free boom it's just right
on the desk
for an hour that's that's my morning
coffee that's that's my shot of caffeine
did you have like did you have like a
purchase because I I feel like we all
had a pretty similar mindset and I'm
pretty sure a lot of people have a
similar mindset where you know in
college you couldn't imagine spending
your money on anything other than things
that will help you survive yeah right
anything like if if if you need if you
need something outside of just you know
video game I don't really count video
games you know because you know everyone
buys video games everyone everyone needs
some entertainment in their lives you
know everyone has I mean it's integral
to my survival yeah yeah yeah okay I
feel like it's integral to my survival
so is like a [__] Netflix subscriber
or whatever right you know or you know
something you know yeah outside of you
know basic you know laptop
um subscriptions or like video games and
you know and food comes after those in
fact
those in universe those were more
necessary to me than having a nice meal
okay I could buy a PS4 right now or I
could not eat Top Ramen for the next 10
months yeah yeah PS4 sounding good
remember the first moment you realized I
have disposable income now what what do
I what do I do with disposable income
there's and yeah yeah I think first time
like I think any of us got like our
first paychecks from YouTube right being
like oh oh no for me it wasn't even
YouTube for me it was [__] the BBC oh
yeah yeah just realizing that yeah
just just to say this is this isn't a
YouTuber conversation right now I
remember getting that first check no
same with the other jobs as well yeah
well I was unemployed before that yeah
actually no that's not true the the
first time I got a paycheck was when I
was working at the ski fields in nisaco
when I was 16. and I used that would you
buy paycheck I bought a 3DS
hell yeah
I was like you know I could I could like
you know maybe go to a nice restaurant
with like some friends or you know go go
out and buy go to a pub or something you
know like yeah something like that and I
was like
I really want to play that new Animal
Crossing though I just don't have the 3D
[__] it I bought a 3DS and that was the
best purchase I ever made yeah I can't
remember what my first one I mean
outside of like I've said like games
like I said I don't really count games
but I feel like if I spend more the
thing I probably spend the most of my
disposable income now on now is it's
probably like meals good food I remember
a point in my life where I could eat the
same thing every day yeah and uh be
satisfied with it I'm still kind of at
that point but sometimes I'm like okay I
kind of want a nice meal like every
every time I can University I just
bought those uh three kilogram bags of
Hester and I would just boil it then
salt it and eat it
[Music]
and I just wanted a meal because I
wanted the game I didn't want to spend
money and you could eat like like two
months like a month worth of meals just
on my pasta for like two bucks is it
insane
I mean just because you can doesn't mean
you should doesn't mean you should I
mean it was just pasta and salt like and
occasionally occasionally I would get
like a I would like maybe put chicken in
it but God your arteries must have been
crying yeah for sure for sure I mean
luckily carbs it was like it was like
lunch at the student things it was like
you could get things that were like wait
like very cheap and so I would eat that
a lot and so I saw that as like me
spending money so I was like okay for
lunch or dinner whenever I'm at home I
have to get something that's cheap right
yeah so I would just make that it was
bad I don't know like to me to me the
peak broke uni student food is cup Ramen
instant instant Ram expensive
ah if you get a three kilogram bag of
pasta it lasts way longer and is way
cheaper than probably oh I would
literally just buy in bulk I would I
would have like I would have like a
literal I would have a literal draw that
was just a Ramen draw yeah I did those
life hacks full of like cup Ramen and
packed Ramen I don't know like to to me
to to me that that's like still the peak
of like broke uni student food I don't
think it was that expensive was it I
don't know maybe it was expensive for me
that's a Ramen I normally like 30p each
one which is not that much but yeah
obviously a through killer like Costco
yeah uh well there was no Costco near me
okay because I would just I would just
buy like I would have like a monthly
shipment of like Ramen either either
from my mum or just like online I
realize now I'm like I go to university
and you know your parents drive off and
I was like wait where do I buy food from
like is the nearest supermarket was like
20 minutes away come on I'm like I don't
have a car when I was back at home food
just spawned dude I was like holy [__]
how do I go to the store to buy this
stuff and I'm just kind of like be like
whenever anyone went to the supermarket
who had a car yeah I was like hey can I
can I join here yeah yeah and luckily
one of our friends did have it so I
occasionally went with them yeah all you
would have to do but again I don't know
what he should do before like when we
started University at the Tesco delivery
thing like I don't know they're just in
Australia they'd you can uh order online
and they'll deliver it to your house
like from a supermarket yeah no we
definitely didn't know that oh yeah
they'll deliver it to you so I did Tesco
Express or direct whatever it was like a
million times right right and the other
dude would just turn up and he would
deliver all your stuff to you oh yeah
which is great we had to pay like a
small fee it wasn't that much yeah for
you into it but it was great you could
order like 500 frozen pizzas which I
then upgraded to
upgraded yeah well you know you really
like I think anything's an upgrade from
[__] stupid there was only so many
times I could do it before I started to
really get like struggling oh my God I
want flavor then I realized that like
oven pizzas are like one pound each for
one meal so it's like okay well I just
started eating oven pizza every day I
think I had I think it was stints where
I would eat Oven Pizza like 20 30 times
a month how much weight did you gain
from that a lot yeah I bet yeah I ate a
lot of [__] you know that's where I
started getting chubby in University I
didn't realize because I just ate
Monster energy drinks and if Ben and
Jerry's was on sale occasionally you
know you're from a cop wants you might
get one you know is that was was that
your biggest not knowing how to adult
moment in University oh for sure when I
realized like [__] it what the [__] do I
eat and I realized I I realized I didn't
know how to feed myself well and I came
to the conclusion that I was
fundamentally too lazy and I would never
enjoy cooking yeah uh so what I would do
is is that like occasionally we would
all take it in turns cooking things yeah
so I kind of we did that occasionally
where we were taking it
that rarely happened I I wish we had
that because I I heard I had heard of
some like households they're like yeah I
click on this day and everyone feeds
everyone and I'm like if I I think I
purposely avoided that kind of household
because I would not know what to cook
I'd be like how do I I can't feed myself
how do I feed several sentient human
beings I'm just imagining like if it's
Connor's turn to like cookies like bring
out the pasta and salt I gotta bang it
for you boys trust me you'll learn to
love it yeah yeah because you know now I
see her like a lot of tick tocks and a
you know a lot of like shorts being like
if if you need to like if you're if it's
like 11 p.m and you don't know what to
cook here's the perfect recipe for you
another guy you're talking yeah yeah you
know what and I look at that I'm like
man I wish I ate this well as I broke
Unison totally fine I I look at that
today and I'm like that's a great
[__] idea who am I doing the same I'm
getting all those spices was super
expensive yeah oh yeah it was it was not
like seasonings and stuff were very
expensive yeah flavor was expensive yeah
like getting getting certain things
you'd be like well if you want um you
wanted like I don't know like uh basil
leaves right yeah that's that's cool and
all and that's great and it would help
but like I they they cost nearly the
same amount as an oven pizza yeah just
for that yeah and so it was kind of like
what the [__] am I like obviously I'm
gonna give the oven pizza and then you
realize oh [__] this is why everyone's
unhealthy in this country because it's
like the oven pizza I just stuck it in
for 20 minutes and boom I have a
delicious meal right I still love Oven
Pizza this [__] is fire non-japan it's
terrible and they don't really have it
no the ones I do have terrible but we
had some pretty good ones and I loved it
yeah it's like damn and then I gotta
clean up when I'm cooking I just I just
Chuck it in the oven no tray I just put
it in did you ever attempt to eat
healthy and uh in the University not
even remotely I don't think there's a
single unique student who attends unless
they're rich but buy healthy I don't
mean like you know actually salads or
whatever but at least trying to keep a
balanced a balanced diet I know not
pizza every day no I've had a couscous
stint all right couscous for like a
couscous for like six months I eat
couscous or couscous and salt yeah no
because you could buy Instant couscous
it would be in a packet right and it
would it was pretty delicious and it was
uh relatively healthy that was that any
different to instant Ramen because it
was way cheaper yeah because it's just a
smaller noodle yeah you could just pour
a bench in a bowl it was like a nice
snack so I would sometimes I would pour
like four in a bowl yeah it'd cost like
a pound and I would just see that yeah
and you pour in a bowl put boiling water
in boom you got instant couscous it's
pretty bomb yeah it was like uh what's
that what's that chef's name the famous
one in the UK uh who did the Yeah Boy
meme oh Ainsley yeah
Ainsley just hit that guy he had his own
business brand and I it would always go
on sale so I used to just buy tons of it
a cupboards full of this I'm okay okay
I'm gonna also I'm gonna say this you
know uh a lot of people clown on Uncle
Ben's but I love Uncle Ben I I think I
think Uncle Ben's is the [__] goat
man the golden rice okay yeah yeah I'm
just saying I'm just saying as an Asian
sometimes I can't be bothered to cook my
rice okay sometimes I just want to put
that [__] in the microwave okay
sometimes I just there would be I would
make some rice and then I'd realize I'd
you know I didn't finish the rice anyway
I'd left it out for too long I'd be like
[__] do I wait 40 to 50 minutes to like
make another batch of rice or do I just
put in a pack of Uncle sometimes you
just want rice right now yeah exactly
exactly I think if
if I had a rice cooker I even I didn't
even know they existed if I knew they
existed and I had one I would eat way
more rice stuff because I just I cooked
like rice the white way yeah like in a
saucepan yeah and then I would strain it
with oh I would once I cooked the rice I
was taught to strain it with boiling
water oh yeah so I would strain it with
boiling water yeah
it tastes like [__] I didn't know why
because it's just literally washing away
all
and so that's you know I I ate it like
that and I sometimes I would make the
you'd make chicken curry because you
could buy those there's so many of them
in the UK because we're obsessed with it
you could easily buy these like one
pound pots of uh chicken curry that you
just literally just uh heat up yeah and
then you you have Curry yeah they were
pretty good all right it wasn't great
but as a uni student it was it was great
if you wanted some Curry yeah for sure
all right important question
rice or bread
in terms of wall in terms of enchants
like General consumption in terms of you
have to pick one the other one
disappears from the world and you can
only have you can only have rice or
bread for the rest of your life with any
Meal which which carbs you pick which
carbs you pick red
I'm I'm I'm you know I'm and that's not
because I'm white
I think there's there's substitutes for
for rice that exist okay so I don't
always need rice I'll be sad I'll be sad
that fried rice is gone no no no don't
be sad no you don't always need bread
but I could always do it I could always
do with some rice man are you telling me
that means that means some of the most
goaded Foods on Earth are gone like
sandwiches and burgers and hot dogs
unless we have onigiri for a reason
right you know that's that's yeah
Japanese McDonald's
right because they have the sandwiches
right next to the onigiri which one do
you go for right okay I'm a sandwich guy
I'm I you know the I do but I do I do
sometimes get on again yeah my God this
is the one time I regret being half
asian
I agree sandwiches better than onigiri
but uh onigiri is like a gamble I feel
like the filling quality you get is so
50 50 and if you get no filling in it I
feel so bad that I just ate a block of
rice I'm like [__] that didn't taste
good and with like sandwiches always
always good you always get the same
level yeah I mean like you'd be giving
up some like goated things like you know
Pizza that would be pizza's gone are you
telling me that you're willing to get
rid of pizza I didn't think about that
you know you know what I would you know
because like to me so to me rice is the
perfect just neutral thing you know it's
just give me any meat it's any kind of
meal and like you need some kind of
neutral filling with that rice is just
rice just plays that role perfectly is
wheat gone is this is this like this is
everything that we've based on is beer
gone no no no no just just specifically
break you know if as is if if you're
good I've come to my decision okay I've
thought about it long and hard I love
both bread and rice okay but I'm gonna
have to say with bread on this one oh
I'm gonna have to say with German side
one day my German side has won yeah just
because I'm thinking about the sheer
variety of breads as opposed to the
sheer variety of rice and rice as much
as I love it a lot of times can be
replaced with bread in a lot of meals
a lot of Asian things but yeah in in the
case with like a Cobb companion yeah a
lot of things can be replaced with bread
like how are you gonna eat soup without
bread now let's go with rice
yeah yeah actually I mean you can but I
shouldn't I know you can actually we do
that in Thailand actually you know
it depends on this you can't you can eat
you can you can I'm telling you I'm
telling you I mean you can't you can
stick your dick in the fridge doesn't
mean you should
I can but I'm not going there is nothing
wrong actually you know depending on the
soup some soup goes so well with rice
you know okay look I get it okay
actually yeah yeah totally like I cannot
imagine eating uh okay and like soup
curry I understand yeah like rice is
probably the better companion but in the
in the wider world of soups
bread is the goat I'm not saying rice is
better than bread I'm just saying you
know it's ripe rice in in in a starving
world in in in a starving World okay in
in a world where aliens have invaded
Earth and you know guns your head rice
or bread which one goes I would I would
be all right I'm keeping the brand I
would be like oh I think I would keep
the rice this isn't like uh katsu's gone
too because that's breading right and
like fried chicken that's bread
technically there's a bit of breading
huh that's true I mean that's that's
true I mean that's that's what you think
that's like flour now that I'm thinking
about it I think that Curry like
Japanese Curry would go bomb with bread
I think oh yeah I feel like we can we
Coco characters get rid of the rice
let's just bread a side of bread and
just scoop it up but that sounds so good
I mean they do the cauliflower rice
which actually goes quite exactly yo
exactly we don't need rice
we have cauliflower cauliflower rice is
so good you know actually in America did
you remember when I ordered that thing I
ordered cauliflower chicken yeah yeah I
didn't know what it was yeah and it
looked like exactly like a piece of
fried chicken on the outside yeah
remember this with the buffalo sauce no
I don't
um no no it's like a it's like a dry rub
it was weird oh and you bite into this
piece that looks exactly like a thick
piece of fried chicken and it was just a
piece of cauliflower yeah it's crazy I'm
sorry it's blew my mind cauliflower is
coated yeah so good like we we have a
bad image of cauliflower because it
seems to be that one thing we always
hated as a kid but no I loved it as a
kid he loved it as a kid yeah in the UK
you always had like cauliflower like a
creamy cheese sauce thing it was always
really good oh that sounds good my
parents wouldn't serve it to me that I
think they thought it was too bad for me
but my friend's house did
yeah I never got that I just got like
the normal boiled cauliflower so yeah me
too yeah I like that too you like that
as well I like okay you just you just
love every vegetable I love veg man
they're just so good carrots man but
every other veg is pretty good all right
all right noodles or pasta
what am I keeping yeah what are you keep
making
like a million times isn't that way oh
no there's a lot of noodles there isn't
all of noodles there's a lot of noodles
I feel like we've had this date I'm
gonna Deja Vu we had this discussion I
feel like I was about to say there's way
more I might have I was about to say
there's way more noodles of pasta uh way
more variation pasta but then I think
you rebuttaled no there was way more
variations I think it might have been
one of our like First episodes where we
talked about like food I don't think
we've what if we're literally reliving
in time and this is like so weird
someone's gonna clip into it I don't I
think we might have had a similar
conversation off camera I don't think
we've had it I you know I I think I feel
like this would I feel like if it is it
would be a bigger meme probably I feel
like I would have seen some memes on the
subway
pasta yeah I'm keeping a pasta
yeah I'm sorry guys I love my noodles
man I just it would feel it would feel
so bad losing out on all of the noodles
all of the ramen
Chinese noodles
but honestly Italians I gotta [__]
give it to you guys you you guys you
guys made something goaded yeah I could
not I could not get it's my favorite
carb it is it is hands down hands down
pasta pasta goated car yeah
I've never met a single person who
doesn't like pasta yeah I know everybody
loves it
it's like Italian cuisine right what
what's what's the most widely seen
Cuisine you've seen around the world
because I think to me it's maybe Italian
it's the easiest one to get no matter
where I go in the world you know
sometimes you find a hard time finding
like you know Mexican restaurants in
America no problem you know sometimes
you have a hard time maybe fighting
French food or you know Thai food you
know
um but like I've never had a hard time
finding an Italian restaurant yeah and
like even you know a lot of people I
think are going to say like Chinese food
but I feel like
that's Chinese food and then there's
Chinese yeah I don't okay here's the
thing I don't think Chinese food exists
right in the sense okay let's get out of
content yeah yeah I don't think it's
real in in the sense where I don't think
Chinese food can be branded as in one
under one umbrella right right do you
know what I'm saying yeah yeah yeah
no because like different parts of China
have different like styles of Cuisines
yeah you're trying to say yeah yeah it's
like the variationally though as well
yeah like the variation in Chinese food
is so [__] like large that if I if I
go to a place and it's just like oh this
is a Chinese food restaurant I'm just
like that's that's us what part what
does that mean what does that mean is it
is it you know cantonin Cantonese
cuisine is it you know
um you know there's China has like so
many different styles of Cuisine that I
would like to know which which part of
China which cuisine am I eating rather
than if it's just Chinese food and I
think this comes from growing up in the
UK
um when it's Chinese food in the UK it's
it's it's awful a lot of Chinese food in
the UK is awful because it's just your
Baseline here is westernized Chinese
food as opposed to actual Chinese
cuisine
um and so finding
funding like actual specialized Chinese
cuisine is a lot harder than finding
good Italian food in my opinion yeah I
want to say that next time I go to a
Panda Express I'm like oh what part of
China is this from yeah yeah
in America is like Belly Chinese food
yeah yeah I had uh I remember having
this argument with uh with a May in
England and I was like yeah I sweet and
sour chicken that's not real Chinese
food you know you go to China and you
try and find sweet and sour chicken
you're not going to be able to find that
you know and he's like no no no no no
it's it's everywhere it's everywhere I
swear to God it's my favorite Chinese
food you know and I'm saying you know
that's kind of like saying orange
chicken yeah like what do you mean I
can't get orange chicken in China it's
Chinese food yeah yeah
um but yeah to me Italian Italians are
goaded with their food and it's also I
think one of the easiest Cuisine to find
Worldwide I've not been to a country so
far where I've had a hard time finding
Italian in a good Italian restaurant
kind of like like anywhere that's true
yeah you got it Italians congratulations
congratulations on the pasta you got
that dog yeah what do you guys think
about French food
uh not as good as Italian I mean it's
all it's all right okay these okay
here's the thing French have the image
of being like you know oh we we have
like the best food you know this is
where all of the culinary like Giants
are you gonna just stop that we have the
best blank French fruits I've used to go
to France every year for like you know
[__] forever yeah for like three
weeks at a time and like french food in
in France was amazing uh and it was so
good like some of the best in the world
yeah the moment you leave France to get
actually good french food you have to
pay out the ass oh yeah yeah whereas I
feel like Italian kind of travels a
little better you can get dishes I feel
like you need to pay out the ass while
you're in Paris as well yeah oh yeah I
mean outside of Paris it's great yeah
yeah you know it's a lot more affordable
to get really good quality stuff
Insurance
um but yeah just it doesn't export well
I think that's the problem is that
Italian kind of like food it's very easy
to kind of make it in more palatable to
whatever culture or whatever country
you're in for an affordable price it's
more customizable yeah yeah yeah and um
I just think yeah France is the problem
where to get really good french food
abroad you have to spend
so that's why it feels like kind of like
more bougie Italian and sometimes you're
like yeah [__] it now I go Italian well
it's it's like French always has I think
everything French has this image that is
bougie yeah French French the language
sounds bougie a lot of the times
um but yeah like I I think one thing I
noticed because
you know you know I've said before that
I spent a lot of money a lot a lot of my
disposable income
um trying out different restaurants
because that's like I guess my favorite
thing to spend money on nowadays
um like going one thing that always
bothers me about going to let's say
fancy restaurants right you know you
know higher tier end restaurants
um is that
everyone's kind of agreed right it's you
know they taste really good is it worth
the price a lot of times no it's not
worth the price a lot of times you go
for the experience you go for this kind
of like rare ingredient that you can't
get anywhere else it's kind of like
you're paying for like the Rarity as
opposed to the how good it tastes a lot
of times
um but one thing that always bothers me
is a lot of like higher class
restaurants I go to they it tastes
doesn't taste the same but they never go
too far of this like taste profile
nothing ever tastes too strong you know
there's there's always like a subtle
hint of something and sometimes I just
want to maybe this is the Southeast
Asian of me talking some I want to see
what happens if some if if there is a
fine dining or a high-class restaurant
that just that just commits to having a
really spicy food of really really
strong taste because obviously that's
not going to appeal to anyone or
everyone
um but I that's that's one thing I would
like to see I feel though those exist
especially in Japan in like the mom and
pop shops right where it's like they're
not afraid to not you know uh pertain to
the what do you mean by mum and pop
shops you know like the locally owned
places yeah that have been around for
like several Generations you know that
maybe specialize in a particular dish or
a particular style of dish yeah because
they're not afraid of alienating the
general yeah consensus like exactly they
just they just want to they're like we
have this one thing yeah and this is our
gimmick and if you [__] with it then you
can come back at any time hell but if
you don't then go somewhere else you
know like they don't care about becoming
like this you know big thing or having
this you know large name in the in the
restaurant world if you will so it's
like you know because like some of the
weirdest [__] I've ever eaten and I've
eaten a lot of weird [__] in my life has
always been in the most like dingy local
places that just don't really give a
[__] they're like yeah this is our weird
thing yo you like it cool thanks I'm
curious about you Joey when when have
you had like a shokugeki moment you know
the [__] you you can take it takes I
mean the cream fried chicken I almost oh
really okay okay and also that's the
first time I went to that skimming place
I took you guys yeah that was Superman
like there are a few dishes that have
made me had the show King moments the
command is like one of those places
there's a lot of Thai Dishes I remember
as a child that still you know sticks
with me until this day
um first time lasagna man of course my
first list I still remember with that
[__] man it wasn't even like a great
lasagna but I'm just like holy [__] sure
holy [__] how can how could you improve
pastor of both yeah that's good yeah
that's good what about you Connor Sonya
just most Foods he has one every day
yeah that's true that's true I think as
long as it's not pasta and salt I'm a
I'm a Nut
anything's a nut he's experienced the
bottom of the barrel so anything else is
above I'm very easy to please with food
um I just want something that makes me
fall and taste good and I'm happy I feel
that's why it was such [__] chefs yeah
yeah because if we actually cared about
food that's why I don't want to I don't
wanna I don't want to get a better
palate I I [__] love what I eat right
now yeah that's true I think I think I
think like I I don't know I think uh
going on a tangent I've tried like
cooking a bit more and obviously I'm
biased but uh I think I could be a
pretty good cook and I think part of the
reason I could be a pretty good cook is
because I'm a really picky eater oh yeah
I want things to taste exactly I have a
have a way that I want them to taste
exactly in my mind and when I get that
I'm like holy [__] this stays fine well
I would argue that's what makes the best
chefs right like they actually care
about what goes into the food and the
small subtleties of what makes a dish
great like if you didn't give a [__]
about it then you'd be like you end up
like Mr pasta and salt over here yeah
where it's just like if it's edible it's
going in my tummy if I had more time I'd
probably cook more because I do enjoy
cooking I do enjoy the final result
there's a lot there's a lot of things I
enjoy in life I enjoy the final result I
don't enjoy the aftermath or some of the
process of what happens before that
final result but when you get that final
result in it's a it's it's really it's
it's so [__] satisfying yeah I sound
like mail-in right now she's rubbing off
on you maybe even hang out with me yeah
going back to Thailand um um
okay
I don't know I don't I don't know if
this is just people that I've uh I've
had around me but there's one thing I've
realized growing up and talking to more
of my Asian friends I don't and I want
to confirm if this is a thing that's
widespread or this is a me thing
okay I can ask you this okay
does every Asian family have the
spiciest [__] Asian drama like the
spiciest family drama just hidden away
somewhere
oh is this just or is this just
something I've just noticed as I've like
grown older about the people around my
friends and my Asian family I don't I
don't think it has to do with an Asian
family I think it just has to do with
big families right because the more
people get involved Yeah the more likely
you're gonna run into someone not liking
someone yeah right because my Asian
family is quite small right
comparatively to other Asian Foods yeah
yeah yeah and as far as I'm concerned
like yeah I don't really know of any
like drama that's happened in your
family yeah I've because I've noticed
this because I've um you know uh because
growing up right growing up
um especially you know especially in a
lot of Southeast Asian families I've
seen you grow up and you you grow up
with a lot of the same like family
values treasure family love your family
and like there's there's a big thing you
know in Thailand where you call everyone
you know Auntie or uncle or cousin or
brother you know you call your you call
your cousin's brother sister and
sometimes you call all family friends
brother and sister and then you call
your Auntie and Uncle Auntie Uncle and
then you call your family's friends
Auntie and Uncle as well yeah right so a
lot of the times with how big the
families are you don't actually know who
your auntie and uncles are
like you know who your aunties and
uncles are uh and then you they'll be
they'll be someone who caught Auntie and
Uncle right and I've confirmed this with
like a few a few friends and you grow up
everything's like everything's great
everything's you know we're a nice big
happy family you grow older and then you
ask around and like
um and and then they'll they'll be this
like they'll be
you'll talk to like one of your uncles
and then they'll they'll mention
something about a family member about
this huge drama that happens before you
were born yeah right and then you
realize oh slow like
this Auntie's not my real Auntie or that
Auntie's not my real Auntie or something
like that now he's [__] I feel like
I'm just like disrupted the core memory
from nappy right now that's so bizarre
I thought I I remember realizing I I
remember thinking I had a normal family
and then As I Grew Older the more like I
I like the more dark history I uncovered
behind behind some of the [__] that
happened like with my not like not my
immediate family but like some of my
extended family yeah and then I remember
like talking to my friends about this
and I was like I had the conversation
with some of my Southeast Asian mates
and I was like yeah this is weird weird
thing I discovered with my family the
other day and they were like oh no
that's that's like five of my aunties
like the best [__]
let alone on one side yeah
I had one friend who was just like yeah
I had this uh I had this auntie that uh
I thought was like my blood related
Auntie for like a long time and I found
out not she's not even like blood
related family at all and then another
another friend was just like yeah uh so
there's this one cousin who I didn't
realize was just like a love child I
guess and just nobody talked about it
now every Asian just have trust issues I
would be like who do I trust dude don't
look at me dog I feel that I feel that's
very salivated not easy [__] maybe
that's why I [__] love all the shitty
romances I do man maybe it's just in my
blood man maybe it's in my place
but we got no problems with my family
yeah
I realized oh like all the cheesy uh
soap operas that I thought were
ridiculous maybe that's like more based
on reality than I first thought you
didn't see the small text this is this
is non-fiction yeah yeah because because
I realize every time you go every it's
especially like the big family
gatherings like every time I've been to
like a family wedding there's some new
piece of information that just gets
Unearthed oh yeah
I don't know we're tangent I wanted to
confirm if it was a me thing or if there
were any other Asians out there that
know what I'm talking about okay oh c
Gang has definitely got your back
foreign
yeah how big is your how big is your
like
it's not very big family yeah not very
big yeah um and even then like when it
when it when you do have cousins you
don't really talk to cousins I I never
ever talk to my cousins do you not do
text your cousins or anything like that
yeah all the time I don't even know
white people thing but like it's like
you don't talk to your cousins unless
it's like an awkward interaction I
[__] love my cousins yeah it's always
like in some kind of setting I feel yeah
it's stuff I feel it's definitely a
white thing because my white side uh of
the family I don't I don't know my white
side I don't even know any of them like
I I don't I supposedly have about like
10 to 15 cousins that all live in
Germany right I ha I don't even know
what they look like I don't know their
names I've never met I feel I feel like
outside of immediate family like I feel
like generally like white people don't
really care that much unless yeah like
unless they're actually like really good
friends with them yeah I think we put
way more importance on like friends yeah
I think yeah it's too many degrees of
separation yeah I think outside of
immediate family it's like no yeah I
have this weird anywhere if it's like if
if they're family and you know
um if they're blood related I feel like
we're all instilled with this value that
you know if they're blood related
they're like they're like a brother to
you they're like assisted you I remember
like one of one of like the weirdest
things that has happened to me is uh
where I actually like discovered
long-lost family once so yeah like I
said uh both my parents have like a very
very big family
um and uh I had I had an uncle who
unfortunately passed away before before
I was born so there was this Uncle that
I just like never knew right uh blood
related blood related okay yes yes yes
yes
I have to I have to clarify yes uh 100
blood PlayStations yeah the 23 I mean
they don't have 15 uncles
sometimes we have like secret uncles who
knows it's [__] Southeast Asian
family drama
um but yeah like I uh had an uncle who I
never knew because he passed away before
I was born
um so so he had a he had a uh so my
uncle uh Michael had a kid uh with
someone from Switzerland right okay
never knew this for the longest time
right
uh and by sheer coincidence right uh we
had a uh it was just me and my mum and
me and my mum and my dad and we had a
family trip to Switzerland uh and we we
were just going for like you know we'd
never been Switzerland before we just
wanted to visit uh and my uh my dad's
uh my dad had an old phone number of uh
of my uncle of his brother that passed
away uh and he was married to you know
someone who was from Switzerland and he
had their phone number
um so he was like you know what let's uh
I we have lost all contacts with my
cousin right who is my dad's I guess my
dad's nephew right hasn't seen him since
uh since his brother passed away uh
let's try phoning this number and see
what happens uh and so we phone it and
someone picks up luckily it's
Switzerland so you know they speak
English as well
um and they said oh sorry this person
doesn't live here but
the pre we could give you the number uh
we can give you the number where the
previous owner moved to right and um and
so we tried we tried finding this new
number and then we we had gotten to like
my my auntie you know
um my you know my my uncles yeah my well
my uncles is it step odds How would how
would you classify this this is too many
degrees this is separation so confusing
now my uncle's wife basically my uncle's
wife okay
um and we've gotten through to them and
then you know my dad had an amazing
moment where we got to like he got to
reconnect with his nephew
um who he had not seen for literal
decades and uh who like my cousin didn't
even like I I think that was the first
time he'd spoken to him because he was
like he was that young when my uh when
my uh when my uncle passed away and so I
had this weird like moment where oh
where my dad where my dad's like uh so
we're gonna meet your cousin now you've
never met your cousin Jesus but uh
but uh your family
uh but like instantly like it was it was
a it was a great moment where uh I I'd
seen him for the first time and um I got
to meet him and I could instantly tell
oh oh he's blood related oh with that
thing like because he looked very very
he had like a lot of similar features to
my dad and it was just this moment where
I had just found long lost family and
I'm like that's awesome yeah I'm like
this is so [__] surreal I don't I
didn't know how to like process this and
I I literally didn't know how to process
this
um but we just like after just one
conversation I'm like
oh okay your family and instantly like
after one conversation he he I could I
could tell there was like he'd at that
time he barely spoke English right
because he was uh more speaking uh
French and German at the time he barely
spoke English but even though I was uh I
was like a teenager back then even
though we could only communicate through
like very very simple sentences I could
I could feel like I could feel like a
bond there and like after after meeting
him and after discovering that I had a
long lost cousin you know every time you
know every time uh he actually started
learning more English as well and we
kind of connected better and uh yeah it
was it was like a long lost family bond
and I'm like that's that's the good part
of that's the good part of family values
not the spicy Asian drama so that's
that's just going to find anyone on my
family tree that I didn't exist so it's
probably a reason why they disappeared
it's like a it's like a double-edged
sword right that's that's like the good
part where you like you meet someone
even if you've never seen them before in
your life there's a family value that's
instilled in you that no matter what if
do you feel like a blood relate if if
their family you know you treat them
like family no matter what
um but then some a lot of Asian families
I feel take advantage of that as well
there are there's always like I know can
I borrow money you're family right and I
remember I remember like there's I
remember the first time I watched some
awards right and the one tangent is this
I don't know okay it it is it is but
like because found like some awards oh
you haven't seen someone that's why I'm
like what okay some of Wars there's like
two parts of some Wars there's one part
that's basically like Digimon the movie
but then there's this other part which
is basically showcasing this big
Japanese family who um who come together
for a family reunion one last time
um it's like 50 of them yeah yeah
there's like 50 of them and there's a
storyline about like the the one black
sheep of the family that nobody talks
about and I swear to God every one of my
Southeast Asian like brethrens there is
ever I don't know why they're just like
me for real there is always that one
black sheep of the family that nobody
talks about but everyone knows about it
all right except if you're a kid you're
like who is this who is who is this man
yeah and we're like
it is
but yeah that's uh yeah I do agree
though with Connor in the sense that
like I feel in a lot of like uh like
Western families it's not so much about
like cousins that you form like a really
close like almost family bond but more
like friends right yeah because in Japan
I feel the equivalent of that is
childhood friends right
okay okay
first hand I can tell you like when you
are childhood friends with someone you
like have grown up with someone ever
since like before you could even have
sentient thoughts yeah it's just you
have that connection even if it's like
five ten years since you met them yeah
the moment you get back together into a
conversation you're like yeah it's like
nothing's changed you know like you can
you could share with them anything that
you want that's so weird though because
it's like I could probably do that with
you know the cousins that I live that
live in Germany that I'm unaware of but
it's like
it doesn't it feels more distant than
someone who has been there my entire
life right even if they're not blood
related so it's very I'm not in contact
with any of my childhood friends
I have more childhood friends than I do
cousins
because I thought it was gonna be about
fighting uh I mean it is in a sense it
has fight against me Wars that was no
yeah
it's like a digital wall yeah yeah I'm
not interested just think of it's
Digimon the movie reskin that's all but
I I liked that's a good movie it's I the
the thing the thing I loved about
someone was was the family aspect
because that's that's the part that I
related with
um because yeah I had a very similar
kind of like I guess family structure
where like my grandmother was like
probably probably like probably like my
like my biggest influence in life
because she was like the family leader
and she like was the linchpin that like
kept him on Twitter or something holy
[__] I'm [__] I'm [__] tearing up
oh [__] like yeah [__] I [__] love
my grandma and like she
grandma if you're watching from Heaven I
miss you I miss you Grandma
um but yeah that's that's what that's
kind of like a big reason why like I
remember Summer Wars was because like I
had a very very similar family structure
to that including all of the drama that
went with that and there's always and I
realized that now I'm that Uncle who has
the weird job because every hunger has a
great job I'm that Uncle who has the
weird job now so what does Uncle do
don't worry about it
we care about each other shout out to
the three people that get that reference
anyway if you like to be the family and
support the show at the same time then
go to a patreon patreon.com trash taste
also follow us on Twitter send us memes
on the subreddit and if you hate our
face listen to us on Spotify and uh
we'll see you guys next week alright see
you guys soon bye
[Music]
thank you